une production du studio SF
iltre le podcast
avec moi dôme plante cette semaine cette
semaine vraiment content de recevoir
Dominique tardif de journaliste culturel
que j'adore écouter j'adore écouter ces
balados j'adore lire ces articles
quelqu'un qui a une culture et une plume
vraiment très fine et aiguisée montrer
puis je lui ai dit dans podcast j'ai
lancé des fleurs mais je dis que c'est
impressionnant de quelqu'un comme ça qui
est autant de bagages culturels
un groupe plaisir de discuter avec lui
on a parlé de en fait beaucoup de ce que
c'est le métier de critiques
comment qu'on approche ça par la
critique au Québec dans ce petit milieu
on se connaît surtout quand les critique
est pas négative ça peut être difficile
on a parlé aussi de qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on aime une musique ou plus qu'une
autre et comment juger depuis quelque
chose est bon quelque chose est moins
bon sur quel critères on se base on a
parlé de
comment il tombait en amour avec la
musique avec l'altération
[Musique]
un gars face dans l'utiliser beaucoup de
mots fascinant
mais c'est quelqu'un juste que comme il
était intéressant avait entendu parler
tout à fait exemple plus attendre mon
podcast bonne écoute le podcast
aujourd'hui est présenté par mendescape
nos amis de chez manscape nos amis de
toujours qui nous supporte et que et
qu'on supporte et qu'on aime réellement
les produits on les utilise moi
j'utilise très souvent le Hulk chasmouth
package qui est avec le petit rasoir le
crop shiver qui est un petit rasoir
vraiment vraiment fin et qui va dans
tous les recoins les plus difficiles
d'accès
et agile depuis très longtemps trois
lames qui qui glissent super bien sous
la peau qui rase avec douceur mais avec
précision
avec le kit avec le gel arrosage et un
petit exfoliant pour avoir une peau bien
douce et pour éviter tout poil incarné
et autres choses désagréables alors un
code promo pH juste avant le code promo
je veux juste faire un charlotte au gars
qui a déjà écrit dans les commentaires
sur Youtube que la seule raison pour en
parler de m'inscris parce qu'on était
payé pour le faire mais oui c'est une
publicité en fait mais on utilise
réellement les produits manscape mais
vous savez c'est une publicité qu'on
fait c'est normal c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne on a un code promo pour vous
et le code sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et la livraison gratuite et si
vous êtes pour commander men's cake pour
vous ou pour un être cher utilisez notre
code et assurez-vous de bien l'utiliser
comme ça ça leur indique que nous on
vous envoie donc ça n'encourage le sans
filtre ça l'encourage vous ça encourage
tout le monde mais tout le monde est
content donc notre promo sans filtre 20%
de rabais et le shipping gratuit merci
mansquée
pour vrai c'est vrai mais c'est quand
même un peu imaginons le monde à chaque
à chaque jour on tente le monde mais
avec une nouvelle compagnie qui nous
paye pas fait genre on fait une minute
de 1h30 de publicité en début mais pas
une publicité juste parce que juste
parce que on traite on veut que le monde
aille une minute trente de messages à sa
tête podcast bref mon podcast
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a commencé ouais on a commencé ça
tourne merci d'être là merci à vous les
gars c'est super
aujourd'hui c'était l'épisode de ton
podcast avec gallopage qui est sorti
puis tu nous disais que tu avais reçu
des emails de merde par rapport à ça
ouais mais il y a certaines personnes
lorsqu'on écrit à leur sujet c'est à peu
près assuré que on peut recevoir une
tonne de courriel Mike word Safia Nolin
Safia Nolin c'est le pire puis c'est
toujours les courriels les plus accats
blancs les plus violents les plus
vraiment je savais ça parce que j'avais
lu là-dessus dans les médias mais
lorsque j'ai écrit à son sujet pour la
première fois puis j'ai eu l'occasion de
lui dire à sa fille après je dis je
comprenais jusqu'à un certain point ce
que tu veux mais j'ai pas la prétention
fait de comprendre ce qui vit mais j'en
ai pris la réelle mesure en écrivant son
sujet beaucoup de courriels des gens qui
souvent écrivent pas son prénom comme il
faut c'est
ils sont très choqués contre Sofiane
Olympia
[Musique]
cristallise une beaucoup de haine mais
autour de la pandémie j'en suis beaucoup
de mimes que je comprends pas vraiment
que je comprends moitié parce que je
pouvais faire des déclarations ici et là
que porter un masque c'est une bonne
idée là ce genre de chose donc pas de
bon sens
amusant parce que dans l'entrevue il
parle de certains de certaines de ces
choses là je lui demande qu'est-ce que
ça te fait que les gens trouvent
arrogant ce à quoi ils répondent quelque
chose comme je m'en colle ici
[Rires]
il y a certaines personnalités comme ça
Mike wide aussi le petit gilet toute
l'histoire de Jérémy Gabriel
le mis sur le radar de plusieurs
personnes qui seraient probablement pas
c'est qui en fait puis il s'imagine
c'est ce qui est drôle aussi c'est qu'il
y a un marge une marge entre ce que les
gens s'imaginent de ces personnalités là
puisqu'ils qui sont en réalité parce que
bon effectivement l'humour de Michael
est quand même assez noir et c'est un
gland mais l'individu est assez et très
gentil très généreux et puis son humour
aussi bon c'est cette blague là je sais
pas pourquoi je me lance
c'est impossible de d'argumenter avec
ces gens-là puis de leur dire non mais
votre lecture de la situation est pas la
bonne puis je pense qu'il vous manque
certaines informations y ont décidé que
Mike Ward c'était un méchant il est dans
la catégorie des méchants même chose
pour Guy à la page même chose pour sa
fier de l'un et puis là après ça ça
entraîne toutes sortes de de mots qui
qui ont aucun sens ce qui est fascinant
avec avec Mike comme exemple précis
c'est que il y a du monde il y a
vraiment fait un clivage cette histoire
là en fait tu as fait un clivage parce
que oui tout le monde qui
qui l'ont connu comme comme tu
l'expliques puis qui lui a pose cette
étiquette là de méchant mais tu as aussi
toutes les défendeurs de Mike Word qui
sont aussi virulents en vert oui ça
c'est déplorable aussi exact mais c'est
il y a vraiment fait comme si dans un
camp ou dans un autre là c'est Michael
de jamais appelé à ce que on dise du mal
où est-ce qu'on
à ce qu'on écrive des choses méchantes
au sujet de Jérémy Gabriel donc
effectivement c'était assez décourageant
de voir que les gens sentent le besoin
de choisir leur camp alors que c'est pas
nécessaire surtout si Mike white ou
Jérémy Gabriel ne sont pas des gens que
vous connaissez personnellement je
comprends que si tu les connais tu te
sens davantage à interpellé mais c'est
si tu les connais pas tu as pas besoin
de choisir ton camp tu peux considérer
la situation de manière plus froide et
surtout pas besoin d'écrire un
journaliste qui fait une entrevue avec
une de ces deux personnes là entrevue
qui ne portaient pas sur ce sujet là par
ailleurs mais c'est drôle parce que tu
sais maintenant dans le cas de mycard ou
dans le cas ça fait mal aussi je dis
même si je
l'endos je la condense mais je peux
comprendre mettons d'où là la colère ou
le le fait de virulence vient mais
j'ai écouté religieusement ton en parle
depuis sa sortie je n'ai pas manqué
beaucoup pitié
il est beau il pose des questions ça il
y a pas particulièrement tranche des
fois des fois il va glisser un peu son
opinion sur des sujets mais je veux dire
somme toute il fait des entrevues je
comprends pas d'où cette espèce de cola
comme si représentait un espèce d'élite
tu sais que mais oui
j'aimerais faire j'aimerais quelqu'un où
je pourrais tenter de le faire puis je
sais pas jusqu'où ça remontrait mais
comment ça commence
dans les yeux de certains est devenu le
président de cette espèce de groupe
sculp qui existe pas de la clé du
plateau puis des bourgeois des bobos je
sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire ça non
plus mais je commencerai les recherches
dans le coin de Québec
où commencer les recherches pour trouver
l'origine de ça je commencerai dans
certaines radio à Québec dans l'entrevue
qui m'a accordé dit c'est drôle qu'on
comprenne pour le boss la clique du
plateau parce que oui j'habite sur le
plateau mais toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises sur le plateau depuis les
20 dernières années je suis contre je
préférais qu'on ait fait le contraire de
ce que nos dirigeants ont décidé donc
c'est ça c'est pas clair d'où ça part
puis effectivement dans le cadre ça
vient de là et cristallise un paquet de
choses qui aux yeux de bien des gens
sont détestables pour des raisons pour
des mauvaises raisons mais qui est la
page c'est moins clair mais c'est ça
twitterienne c'est jamais bon pour oui
c'est ça c'est à dire pour le climat
social il y a quitter Twitter mais il
répondait peut-être pas systématiquement
mais il répondait beaucoup plus que
d'autres personnalités assez détracteurs
pendant tout le monde en parle mais je
pense que c'est ce les éditions tout le
monde en parle qui ont été diffusés
pendant la pandémie puis qui parlait
forcément beaucoup de la pandémie
on va tirer on attirer l'attention de
bien des gens dont on n'est pas obligé
de parler plus longtemps on appelle on a
fait le tour des violets cette question
là on en a parlé en masse aussi c'est
sur le Podcast
que je fais à la presse dans le cadre de
mes fonctions de journalistes à la
presse maladeau qui ressemble un peu
la continuité finalement c'est un autre
nom exactement mais qui me permet de
bénéficier donc de la visibilité de la
presse puis de faire ça dans le cadre de
mon travail plutôt que de faire ça à
côté dans mes temps libre parce que vous
savez les gars que faire un baladeau ça
peut être c'est payant de ne pas on le
voit
moi
mais j'allais dire que c'est chronophage
aussi ça prend quand même pas mal de
temps parce que non seulement les
enregistrer mais il faut se préparer il
faut les monter les mettre en ligne tout
ça donc c'est quand même chouette de
pouvoir
me dire d'importance comme la presse
aussi se lance dans
merveilleux du balado
indépendante
tout à fait c'est moi et mon ami
Jean-Michel Bertillon qui s'occupe de
tous les aspects techniques j'aurais
juste au studio madame wood je viens de
te donner un peu près tous les
intervenants
mais ce qui est quand même en fait le
point de départ de beaucoup de projets
de podcast ouais mais il y a j'imagine
que vous en avez reçu beaucoup de ce
genre de message là mais j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages de gens qui me
demandaient bon Dominique j'aimerais
lancer mon propre baladeau peux-tu
m'aider est-ce que ce que je peux
t'appeler le port du stage de réponds
oui pour genre un peu les gens sont
toujours bah j'essaie de donner un petit
coup de main aux gens je suis sûr que
vous faites la même chose après quelques
années
vous venez au studio SF puis on va vous
arranger ça c'est sûr que vous répondez
avec des gens qui se questionnaient à
savoir quoi faire par où commencer
souvent les réponses sont les mêmes mais
puis les gens sont souvent déçus bien il
arrive à la question alors comment je
fais pour financer mon Baladou bah je
sais pas tout tu dois avoir un compte en
banque c'est comme ça que tu vas le
financer
tu peux choisir ton mode de paiement
préféré mais c'est à peu près comme ça
que ça fonctionne ouais mais là si je
veux le vendre à tel média si ça se peut
puis il y en a jamais oui sauf que il y
a plus de chance
que tu fasses dire non que le contraire
puis de toute façon
la réponse que je leur donne aussi c'est
pas les bonnes raisons il y a quand même
quelque chose de charmant dans le monde
du balado puis qui qui s'est perdu avec
les années mais il y a un côté
un côté un peu Far West c'est à dire on
le fait par nous-mêmes avec nos moyens
on prend nos propres décisions puis on
fait ça de manière un peu
j'appartiens au monde des médias
traditionnels mais il y a quand même une
liberté dans le monde du balado qui est
qui est achiré puis ce que je dis à ces
gens là c'est par ton projet de toi-même
tu vas acquérir des habiletés tu vas
apprendre des choses puis une fois que
tu que tu vas arriver devant des gens
qui veulent te donner de l'argent pour
que tu si ça se produit ben tu auras
déjà une expérience qui va permettre de
mieux répondre à leurs questions puis de
savoir dans quoi tu lances là puis
est-ce que toi d'avoir de faire ce
projet-là dans le dans le contexte dans
le cadre de la presse est-ce que tu sens
que cette liberté là tout à fait 100%
absolue mais en fait quand j'ai été je
sais pas je crois que je suis pas super
raconter ça comme c'était super grave
des conversations qu'on a eu dans des
bureaux là
verrouillée quand j'étais engagé à la
presse
mes conversations avec les patrons il y
avait des questions de ça que
éventuellement une fois que une fois
bien Ancelle que je puisse lancer un
projet de balado parce que les gens qui
m'ont engagé à écouter devient discuter
voulu qui semblait apprécier ce que je
faisais là donc moi ça me réjouissais
bien sûr parce que mais pour toutes les
raisons que je numérique
donc non non je sens vraiment que
les gens s'imaginent que dans un journal
les patrons nous disent beaucoup quoi
faire mais je sais pas si c'est parce
que moi je jouis beaucoup de liberté
mais c'est pas tellement le cas on nous
demande de couvrir certains sujets mais
la plupart du temps c'est nous qui
devons générer nos propres idées puis
c'est une bonne manière d'être
une carrière puis d'être investi puis
d'être apprécié de ses patrons des gens
qui nous engagent et trouver ses propres
sujets puis ensuite évidemment les gens
relisent nos textes puis ils
s'intéressent au contenu mais après ils
vont pas intervenir de manière si lourde
que ça puis ils vont pas réécrire noter
s'il faut que ton article soit réécrit
de A à Z parce que tu es peut-être pas
en train de faire la job que tu devrais
faire donc les patrons dans le monde des
médias sont pas si interventionnistes
que ça ou dans le meilleur des mondes
ils sont pas puis donc moi j'ai vraiment
la chance de jouer de la chance de jouer
d'une très très grande liberté de
liberté immense
je pourrais compter sur les doigts d'une
main le nombre de fois on me dit
non Dominique pas sujet là puis c'était
pour des raisons du genre ta semaine est
déjà bien remplie avec d'autres sujets
et on aimerait que tes articles rentrent
à l'heure et donc au moment prévu donc
ajoute pas un autre article à ton agenda
de la semaine mais sinon on me laisse
pas mal faire ce que je veux si tu
choisis vraiment mettons j'ai vu
dernièrement tu as fait le la critique
de l'album des Foo Fighters si tu penses
que tu as déjà je veux faire ça c'est
vraiment un truc plus simple du genre
voici les albums qui paraissent cette
semaine qui dans l'équipe veut s'occuper
de ceci qui lève la main
le plus que je connais un peu les Foo
Fighters je connais pas je connais assez
bien leur travail puis je m'intéresse au
rock je dis je vais m'en charger mais
sinon pour des articles plus
des articles de fonds des articles plus
élaborés des reportages plus longs c'est
souvent c'est chacun des journalistes
qui propos ce sujet j'aimerais ça comme
le ce week-end j'étais à la semaine
dernière ça a été publié ce weekend
j'étais à lac mes garantie pour parler
bon de différentes initiatives
culturelles qui qui ont lieu là-bas dans
le contexte du dixième de la tragédie
ferroviaire puis c'est moi qui ai
présenté ça mes bosses puis on dit ah
ben ça nous intéresse ça semble ça sent
bien vas-y dominer qui est mais ça c'est
vraiment une histoire est-ce que tu es
maintenant si ça m'intéresse vraiment le
le
raisonnement derrière tout ça comment
est-ce que tu arrives à penser à ce
cette histoire-là si tu penses qu'il y a
comme des des communiqués de presse qui
qui sont lancés en design nous on fait
tel activité dans le cadre du 10 ans
puis le étudiant ça serait intéressant
comme sujet ou c'est juste que tu penses
activement
que ce serait un bon sujet de
ben il y a plusieurs manières d'arriver
aux idées c'est toujours difficile
d'identifier comment on a des idées mais
je suis constamment en train de penser
et puis ça agace même parfois les gens
dans mon temps dans mon entourage
comment je suis
constamment en train de réfléchir à
comment je pourrais prendre cette
affaire-là qui m'intéresse puis en faire
un sujet d'article mais ça c'est quand
même un bon indice c'est à dire que si
il y a quelque chose qui t'intéresse
ou des fois je fais un tweet puis là
c'est juste une idée qui me passe par
l'esprit puis ça réagit de manière très
très forte il y a peut-être il faudrait
peut-être que je crie ça davantage et
peut-être un article là-dedans mais pour
répondre à ta question de manière plus
précise dans le cas de mégantique c'est
parce que ma blonde est originaire de
mégantique donc on y va quand même assez
souvent je connaissais certaines des
initiatives donc c'est je parle dans mon
article mon reportage porte sur les
projets des frères la vallée qui sont
trois gars dans la fin 20e début
trentaine
qui se sont investis à l'acte mégantique
parce qu'ils ont des liens familiaux
leur père vient de là il y a une salle
de spectacle qu'ils ont fondé ensemble
la chapelle Durand où j'avais eu
l'occasion d'aller donc là en sachant
que le dixième de la tragédie s'en
venait puis aussi qu'on a beaucoup parlé
au cours des derniers mois de mé pour
des raisons mais pour ces raisons-là
parce que la série de Sophie lorrain qui
était diffusé le documentaire de
Philippe Falardeau très pertinent
documentaire de Philippe Falardeau je
vois quand même ça intéressant de donner
une autre perspective aussi sur ce que
cette communauté là devenait donc il y a
aussi cette préoccupation là qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'on a mis de l'avant par
rapport à mes gantique qu'est-ce que moi
je connais une mégantique puis qu'est-ce
qui manque dans le portrait que je vois
c'est le portrait médiatique de Mégantic
ressemble à ça moi d'après mon
expérience je pense qu'il manque cette
affaire là que je pourrais ajouter un
blanc donc là dans ce que dans ce cas-là
c'est ce que j'ai fait puis aussi à la
presse dans les derniers mois une sorte
de préoccupation de plus en plus grande
qui présente chez nous lecteurs
électrices de raconter des histoires
plus positives le plus lumineuse parce
que évidemment le journal est rempli de
raisons de désespérer puis de plus en
plus de gens qui laissent tomber les
médias traditionnels pour ces raisons-là
tout ça est discutable puis je pense que
c'est quand même important d'être au
courant de tout ce qui se passe
terrible et de triste dans le monde
parce qu'on peut souvent prendre des on
peut le lutter contre tout ça à notre
manière mais bon c'est quand même
intéressant aussi je pense c'est
pertinent de et nécessaire salutaire de
raconter des histoires qui peuvent
nourrir autre chose en nous mais c'est
intéressant ça c'est un virage
très très virage conscient par rapport à
notre journal il y a une demande pour
quelque chose d'un peu plus
si je me trompe pas François cardinal
qui est notre patron écrit un texte
là-dessus mais oui je pense que
le journal prend le coup de ce que les
gens qui lisent
pense puis pour de plus en plus de gens
puis ça a été documenté la lecture du
journal Le Matin ça devenait une sorte
de boulet le tige commence ma journée
j'ouvre le journal
juste le goût de me lancer par la
fenêtre donc évidemment que tous les
sujets qui donnent envie de se lancer
par la fenêtre bon encore on va pas
comme faire assembler il continue à
exister c'est pas parce qu'on veut pas
s'y intéresser qui vont s'en aller comme
par magie mais ça peut être intéressant
c'est pas comme si les autres histoires
ont les inventait toutes pièces laissez
pas de la fiction ça se déroule pour
vrai le reportage que j'ai fait avec mes
cantique c'est des de victime qui se
déroule là puis qui sont réjouissantes
pour vrai je suis allé à une usine de
chocolat
l'idée c'est pas de c'est pas d'écrire
ce genre de texte là puis faire semblant
que tout le monde il est gentil et puis
mais je pense que juste de changer de
perspective parfois ça peut
ça a été beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles
après mauvaise nouvelle du temps puis il
y en a encore mais je pense que je pense
que qu'on constate présentement c'est
qu'elle les effets délétères de la
pandémie il se poursuitent les fesses
sur
notre état de santé psychologique à nous
ça va pas ça va pas se terminer
immédiatement c'est pas dès que les
mesures de confinement se sont terminés
nous voici de retour à la normale donc
je pense que ça ça va avoir aussi un
effet à long terme sur sur les médias
avant la pandémie nous probablement le
podcast qu'on a fait qui le plus écouté
le plus partagé encore aujourd'hui puis
celui duquel du moins moi je me fais le
plus parler c'est un podcast avec Sonia
Lupien qui est une chercheur Université
de Montréal
en stress qu'elle avait dit avant même
la pandémie c'était que si vraiment tu
as des problèmes de stress plus
d'anxiété une des choses à faire par
courte période c'était comme arrête de
les renouveller
c'est comme une façon de
reseter pendant un petit bout pour
essayer de retrouver une espèce de
stabilité mentale c'était des troubles
anxieux ça c'était avant la pandémie où
est-ce que là ce qu'elle exprimait c'est
que tout le temps des nouvelles
négatives mettons la plupart du temps ou
c'était du moins c'était ce qui te
marquait le plus que la pression la
pandémie est arrivée et puis le c'était
encore plus démarqué fait que c'est sûr
que ça le reste un pack là mais en même
temps c'est tellement important c'est
comme moi aussi des fois là j'ai envie
de décrocher mettons déjà je veux plus
savoir ce qui se passe l'arrêter de m'en
parler je veux plus savoir
que la planète est en train de flamber
exactement
d'hygiène médiatique mais en tout cas je
pense que de raconter d'autres types
d'histoire ça peut aussi créer une
espèce de ça peut contrebalancer l'effet
parfois négatif sur sur notre santé
mentale de toutes les mauvaises
nouvelles qu'on lit puis qu'on l'entend
puis toi ça va être parti en fait c'est
de la tous les journalistes
principalement culturels en fait tu
t'intéresses à des choses le fun c'est
en général du temps en général ça c'est
le fait bon il m'arrive d'avoir des
conversations un petit peu plus chargée
avec des artistes je sais pas si
quelqu'un lance un album oui a écrit un
livre sur le deuil de son père c'est sûr
que la conversation va peut-être d'une
nature différente mais en général les
gens que je rencontre d'une part sont
heureux de me voir mais pas de me voir
moi mais ils sont heureux que un média
s'intéresse à leur travail puis ouais
donc c'est ce mon travail est quand même
du nom de nature que celui des gens qui
couvrent le palais de justice par
exemple ou qui couvre la politique
je suis content de recevoir parce que
petit quand j'écoute ton pote casser on
fait un peu si tu veux le même la même
famille de podcast dans ce qu'on a des
conversations avec des gens qu'on reçoit
et on parle d'eux puis on parle d'un peu
c'est quoi
c'est pas du tout la conversation tu
sais puis je trouve que quand je te lis
aussi je l'ai écrit critique puis je
trouve que premièrement c'est super
bonne interviewer puis tu apparais que
tu as un bagage culturel quand même très
vaste puis je trouve vraiment une très
belle plume puis je peux continuer ces
gens-là mais je suis toujours en fait
curieux [__] tu es quand même jeune je
t'attends à la trentaine puis on dirait
que tu étais déjà 37 ans
un bagage impressionnant fait que je
suis toujours curieux de savoir c'est
quoi en fait
qu'est-ce que comment tu es devenu ce
que tu es devenu dans le sens que c'est
ça a commencé où c'était veille là c'est
curiosité là pour pour les heures pour
la culture puis
vaste question tout ça a commencé à
avoir mais sélectionner mais je pense
que je pourrais attribuer mon intérêt
pour la culture à différents facteurs
mais certainement bon à mes parents puis
à ma mère qui s'est assuré qu'il y a des
livres chez nous puis aussi que c'est
assuré que je peux aller voir des des
spectacles il paraît qu'il y a assez tôt
je manifesté ce désir là d'aller voir
des spectacles
5 ou 6 ans je suis allé voir Luc de la
Rochelière en spectacle au Théâtre du
ski avec ma mère bien sûr j'étais
accompagné
[Musique]
puis
l'anecdote veut que ma mère raconte avec
le plaisir à chaque occasion qui se
présente avec d'autres vœux que je me
suis endormi pendant le spectacle parce
que j'étais petit j'étais tard donc je
me suis endormi devant le pauvre je
m'excuse si écoute c'est pas le Castille
Luc je suis vraiment désolé
je suis pas capable de conserver
l'attention
mais donc on est assez tôt aller voir
quand même pas mal de spectacles j'ai
des souvenirs clairs puis très précieux
de ces moments-là avec avec mes parents
puis ensuite ces musiques plus vraiment
je dirais jamais assez comment music+
c'est triste que d'autres vecteurs pour
la culture aujourd'hui qui se trouve sur
sur Internet et sur les réseaux sociaux
mais ils sont quand même d'une nature
différente puis il y avait quand même
quelque chose avec musique plus d'Auton
on se moquait quand même beaucoup à
l'époque parce que les animateurs
étaient parfois inexpérimentés puis
l'esthétique de musique plus c'était
très agité bon les les plans les fameux
plans sur le côté comme ça mais il y
avait quand même une richesses
culturelle à l'antenne la musique plus
ne serait-ce que parce qu'il présentait
des clips de toutes sortes d'artistes
des artistes qui jouaient pas à la radio
donc tout ce qui est musique alternative
le si aujourd'hui chez seki groovid
c'est parce que les clips de grooveil
Park jouer la musique plus crimes quand
tout ça donc un accès à une autre
manière de penser aussi parce que c'est
aussi ça la musique c'est un
divertissement puis bon c'est ça nous
rend heureux au quotidien mais c'est
aussi une manière de voir le monde c'est
écoute grims gang plus soudainement tu
dis où tu vois le clip de semi-alping
Spirit pour la première fois puis tu dis
ah j'ai le droit d'exprimer ma colère de
cette et non seulement j'ai le droit
d'exprimer mais il y a une autre
personne qui m'a l'air très intelligente
qui sent cette même colère là je
commence à sentir un poids 11 12 ans
pour des raisons que je saurais pas
expliquer pour l'instant c'est donc tous
ceux qui précieux puis il y avait plein
de missions
à chaque semaine dans la musique plus tu
avais une émission fax une heure de
reportage d'entrevue avec des artistes
internationaux et québécois des titres
des entrevues quand même assez
substantielle des 10-15 minutes avec un
artiste donc
depuis juan-noranda c'était quand même
un accès vraiment privilégié à la
culture si tu avais l'impression d'être
au cœur de Montréal toutes les fois que
je passe dans les devant les anciens
studios de Montréal de musique plus à
Montréal il y a pas une fois où je
repense pas assez moment là où je
regardais musique plus à Rouen puis je
me dis ça tombe un air cool Montréal
mais il y a French be qui est en
entrevue en studio à musique plus
présente
les Beastie Boys qui débarquent puis tu
sais des artistes majeurs les moins
majeur que je me disais si seulement je
pouvais aller voir ces choses à Montréal
donc musique place a vraiment joué un
rôle marquant puis Claude rajote le
cimetière décédé évidemment
mes premiers héros puis j'ai encore
beaucoup d'admiration pour lui c'était
l'exemple en fait des critiques
musicales de l'époque le témoin aux
États-Unis puis dans le monde
anglo-saxon il y a toute la culture de
de l'écrit le journaliste musical écrit
niveau de du magazine Rolling Stones le
jeu je simplifie l'histoire du
journaliste musical mais bon ça a pas
mal commencé autour de crime puis de
Rolling Stones magazine mais au Québec
cette tradition là elle a existait dans
dans les journaux puis il y en a
certains représentants mais il y a pas
la grande tradition du magazine du
Québec rock qui a duré quelques années
dans les années 80 qui est un magazine
important mais sinon c'est vraiment
musique plus qu'un carnet ça puis la
grande figure du critique rock en tout
cas dans mes yeux à moi c'est c'est
Claude rajoute puis il m'a aussi appris
qu'on pouvait penser à la musique que
cette manière là qu'on avait le droit de
trouver que ça c'est pas bon puis que
c'est d'avoir des opinions très très
tranchées et arrêté parfois même
violente sur sur certains artistes sur
certains albums c'était correct dans une
certaine mesure
donc la musique plus joué un rôle majeur
puis c'est dans le suivant des gens qui
disent des artistes qui disent il y a
personne qui rêve de devenir journaliste
culturel ou qui rêvent de devenir
critique c'est mon rêve de devenir
artiste
sympathiques de Robinson le bois mais
dans mon album des finissant en 6e année
au primaire à côté de ma photo puis le
mon rêve la profession de rêve de
Dominique c'était critique musicale donc
tu deviens ce que tu as voulu
excellentes
j'ai joué de la musique entre-temps puis
je jouais déjà de la musique à ce moment
je vois de la batterie j'en ai joué
pendant mon adolescence puis
éventuellement j'ai abandonné parce que
je t'ai mais bon aussi parce qu'un drum
ça prend beaucoup de place
j'ai transité par Sherbrooke mais c'est
ce dès le moment que tu quittes la
maison familiale la batterie qui tourne
dans le sous-sol il faut la mettre
ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs les pas
toujours pas toujours trouvable puis
aussi vraiment c'est ça l'idée que
chantait puis je l'ai compris j'ai
réussi à mettre des mots là-dessus plus
tard mais j'aimais beaucoup jouer de la
musique avec mes chats James parce qu'il
y a une espèce de diverses depuis des
fois il y a quelques bières aussi
mais aussi bon l'ivresse de la musique
partagée ensemble on joue puis on se
trouve donc un bon présentement mais
les vrais bons musiciens en général sont
des gens qui développent une espèce
d'obsession puis comme le récemment
récemment je recevais Lisa LeBlanc à mon
podcast de commencer à jouer la guitare
c'est tout c'est temps libre c'est passé
avec sa guitare puis moi j'avais
vraiment pas vraiment sur le avec ma
batterie donc les gens qui qui sont bons
qui ne viennent bon avec un instrument
de Vietnam parce qu'ils ont sans doute
un talent d'une part de talent inné mais
aussi parce que
c'est le nourrit là où ton obsession
ton obsession te valide dans ton
obsession parce que c'est le fun de
sentir que tu es bon en jouant d'un
instrument alors que moi chanter
chantera
en écouter puis aussi que ça m'a mis un
peu plus de temps à découvrir que je
pouvais avoir ce plaisir là écrire parce
que quand tu as 11 ans bon j'ai fait des
des écrits des critiques d'album dans le
journal de mon école primaire
10 sur 10 à l'album de Fast balle j'ai
dit que face bar allait où est-ce que
vous vous souvenez de face Bâle il y a
eu un seul hit qui s'appelait doré
tu l'entendais mais
merci de vérifier
vous êtes trop podcast qui serait
vraiment grand chanteur moi je trouve
que tu viennes prouver le contrat et
voilà
sauf que tu étais un
avec cette chanson dans le pH vienne
nous offrir
avec Survivor mais j'ai réécouter
l'album récemment je me souviens
justement c'est parce que dans le
journal on écrivait on avait été appelé
rubrique où tout le monde racontait
la critique qui regrettait le mot je
racontais que la critique que je
regrette c'est la première critique que
j'ai mais je regrette pas
que je serai amusé parce que j'ai écrit
mais donc les autres occasions quand
même de s'exercer à écrire faire des
entrevues avec des musiciens puis écrire
des critiques de disques qui sont pas
nombreuses quand 16 ans ça arrivait pas
souvent donc le moment où j'ai découvert
le plaisir que je pouvais avoir à faire
ça mais c'est quand j'ai commencé à le
faire professionnellement les un moment
où j'écris des articles pour Bang Bang
puis voir un peu plus tard c'est à
partir de ce moment-là il y a quand même
c'est agréable de faire ça puis bon
c'était pas très bon ce que j'écrivais à
ce moment là ça m'a pris quelques années
pour pour finir pour finir mon écriture
surtout mes
techniques d'entrevue comme apprendre à
faire une autre vue si c'est quand même
c'est quand même quelque chose puis ça
peut s'apprendre à l'école mais je suis
pas allé j'ai pas étudié un journaliste
donc il fallait que que je la prenne par
moi-même en faisant beaucoup d'erreurs
puis en réalisant qui c'était mieux de
se préparer et d'avoir préparé quelques
questions qui se dire je vais me pointer
le puis on va avoir le bas on va voir
une conversation relax parce que surtout
quand tu commences en journaliste
culturel tu sais moi j'habitais à
Sherbrooke donc le interview des
artistes locaux qui sont très gentils
mais qui a pas beaucoup d'expérience en
matière d'entrevue qui pour les gens qui
accordent des entrevues c'est aussi un
apprentissage de savoir quoi pas dire
comment parler de son travail de
création parce que en général les
musiciens vont dire des choses comme ah
c'est venu d'instin j'ai pas vraiment
réfléchi avant de décrire cette chanson
là bon c'est ça c'est ça
oui mais il y a pas grand chose à faire
ça va pas ça va pas donner l'article le
plus intéressant c'est l'histoire d'une
journée musicale donc eux aussi ont un
apprentissage à faire puis c'est pour ça
que j'allais dire assez rapidement mais
pas si rapidement que ça j'ai appris
qu'il fallait que je me prépare parce
que eux aussi avait un apprentissage à
faire puisque si tous les deux on savait
pas quoi dire ça vous apprenez ça job
c'est ça
ce qui est drôle c'est que tu sais c'est
comme si
c'est comme pour certains ça serait un
genre de phénomène nouveau là que comme
les nouveaux jeunes artistes se
comportent comme ça mais il y a rien de
nouveau là-dedans dans le sens que
dans Youtube
c'est les mêmes gens qui ont cripé sur
Robert Charlebois ou sur Jean-Louis tu
sais que j'allais dire sur j'allais
loups qui le trouve dont attachant
puisqu'ils dont drôle puis donc dans
spécial mais dans le bon sens puis que
là que les nouveaux artistes qui
arrivent avec des personnalités
originales puis que c'est comme un nom
j'aime pas commenter on dirait que comme
un
oubliés collectif de comme d'un homme
mais ça a tout le temps était ça des
artistes là mais il y a peut-être aussi
un peu là-dedans de la survalorisation
de ce qu'on appelle l'authenticité
genre le loup on n'avait pas on voyait
Jean Lelou une fois par je voulais
lancer un album une fois par 4,50 le
seul entre l'amour et sans pitié puis le
dos mieux plusieurs années que ce soit
écoulé il était pas sur Médiatis il
était pas présente tant que ça donc
lorsqu'on le voyait on avait accès à
seulement
sur les réseaux sociaux qui nous
présente son chien son chalet etc donc
peut-être une sorte de tension entre ces
deux affaires là de fausses qui fait que
là c'est difficile de savoir à qui on a
accès mais effectivement les artistes
qui se comportent de manière étonnante
en entrevue ça a pas été inventé par les
années 2020 il y en avait une coupe
avant
l'idée de juste rebondir sur juste que
tu viens de dire là changer un petit peu
de sujet mais
je suis la première fois en fait que que
je réfléchis à ce que tu aimes
mentionner du fait qu'avant il y avait
tu avais aucun accès aux artistes autres
que l'aurore dans le fond puis que
maintenant les artistes se mettent
eux-mêmes enseignes sur les réseaux
sociaux puis on en parlait ce matin
justement avec Tik Tok puis Instagram
ça on dirait pas que ça devait nature le
truc mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un
clivage je sais pas comment je me sens
par rapport à ça parce que la première
fois que je le j'y réfléchis mais il y a
quand même un bon un bon
une bonne séparation quand même entre
deux choses-là puis comment est-ce
qu'après tu peux prendre l'or juste pour
ce qu'elle est sans que ça soit teinté
par le fait que tu sais que la personne
finalement même sa chambre sur des
peines d'amour et est en couple heureuse
dans sa vie là d'une part c'est à dire
que puis c'est d'autant plus le cas par
exemple pour les acteurs de tous les
acteurs vont dire j'essaie de me
préserver de pas trop me montrer sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que ou pas juste
de pas aller participer à des quiz à
outrance parce que après les gens ils me
voient dans un film dans une télé puis
là il voit juste la personne que je suis
et non le personnage que je suis en
train d'essayer de créer mais en ce qui
concerne les musiciens
il y a clairement c'est ça c'est à dire
que
il y a de plus j'entends de plus en plus
d'artistes dire c'est difficile
c'est presque douloureux lancer un album
parce que tu travailles là-dessus
longtemps il y a un moment où tu le
lance le vendredi tu lances un album là
tu l'as lancé ça s'en vient vendredi
puis il y a des extraits qui sont parus
avant au compte-goutte pour c'est faire
mousser la tension le tu lances ton
album avec le vendredi j'imagine que tu
reçois un paquet de messages comme
lorsque vous lancez un nouvel épisode de
votre podcast allez bonne entrevue avec
un tel une telle mais après c'est
terminé les gens donc le temps qu'on
passe avec des oeuvres et de plus en
peut-être de plus en plus restreint
parce qu'on a accès toute la musique du
monde donc ça fait que il y a quelque
chose de
forcément douloureux là-dedans parce que
top consacrer tout ce temps-là à créer
quelque chose les gens consomment un
week-end un week-end c'est réglé alors
qu'avanté ton album sortait les gens
allaient l'acheter ou à chambour le
mardi mais il y avait peut-être aller
l'acheter
[Musique]
il est pas de stimuli externe là il y a
pas d'écran
seul avec toi-même donc c'est ça ça peut
coûter une bonne idée à ce moment-là
mais
puis je pense que c'est d'autant plus
important pour les artistes parce que le
travail de création il suppose une
certaine introspection c'est qui Charles
seguin qui me disait
mais je suis allé le rencontrer
à Saint-Venant ça faisait ça faisait un
bout de depuis le début de devient
discuter voulu j'essaie de le bouquet et
puis Richard mais justement mais c'est
tout à son honneur et genre c'est gain
il sort de Saint-Venant quand il y a une
bonne raison et puis
passe
de pas être une raison suffisante pour
sortir de ce moment mais ça il vient pas
à Montréal pour rien puis il valorise la
patience donc oui Dominique je veux je
veux participer à ton balado mais
[Musique]
mais je pense qu'on gagnerait tous être
un peu plus comme
je veux dire une belle phrase on
gagnerait tous à être plus comme méchant
puis à se permettre puis à créer les
conditions pour qu'on soit seul avec
nous-même mais c'est d'autant plus le
cas lorsque tu as les pêcher au fond de
toi des nouvelles idées des nouvelles
chansons qui sont forcément liées à
quelque chose de d'intime chez toi mais
c'est ça le problème c'est le paradoxe
aussi avec être un artiste en 2023 c'est
que ce travail là il faut le faire mais
en même temps tu es appelé à être
présent sur les réseaux sociaux à
toujours alimenter
très compliqué parce que d'une part tu
reçois de la validation donc ça c'est
c'est très grisant mais aussi
effectivement il faut que tu sois sur
mais je pense que tu sais j'ai fait j'ai
fait j'ai fait un tweet là-dessus parce
que ça m'amuse que je parle de mon
Twitter comme c'était quelque chose de
super important ce n'est pas du tout
mais j'investis beaucoup de temps sur
Twitter trop tard est-ce que c'est le
mot que tu voulais vraiment utiliser bah
j'aurais peut-être dû envoyer un autre
mais tu sais il y a beaucoup d'artistes
qui vont faire des pauses du genre mardi
je vais sortir le premier extrait de
sérieux on sait pas qui tu sais comme
c'est pas grave le sors là ta chanson
puis on l'écoutera si on veut l'entendre
et comme si c'est Coeur de Pirate qui me
dit mardi je vais sortir une nouvelle
chanson là ça je pense que beaucoup de
gens qui vont être heureux d'apprendre
cette information
à l'écoute puis le paradoxe c'est que
cœur de pirate pour se permettre de
sortir une chanson sans l'annoncer ça va
créer ça va créer un buzz tout de suite
évidemment je vais même chose pour
Taylor Swift le métier et après il y a
un paquet d'eau d'artistes qui
investissent beaucoup de temps tenter de
créer un buzz alors qu'il y a pas
vraiment de base à créer puis que la
chanson parlera d'elle-même ou pas mais
c'est pas tout ce que tu vas mardi
exactement il y a beaucoup de ce genre
si on est limite tous ces postes là des
réseaux sociaux là il me semble que on
vient d'éliminer une bonne partie
sauf que la triste réalité triste la
réalité en fait c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
dois prendre ma maison de disque on a
parlé pas plus tard que ce matin
tout le tout le package autour de la
musique qui est pris en compte dans le
sens que ta personnalité
engagé avec le monde à être intéressant
puis à créer un engagement puis des fois
s'engagement à l'oeil même pas créé par
nécessairement ta musique mais juste par
ton personnage en ligne puis regarder ça
suivi par 60 000 personnes m'intéressant
tandis que cette personne là est-ce que
en terme artistique a quelque chose à
offrir d'intéressant peut-être que oui
peut-être que non c'est clair que les
deux sont liés tu prends l'exemple d'une
artiste comme feby Rogers là
compositrice fabuleuse mais c'est à peu
près clair que sa présence en ligne sur
Twitter sur Instagram à jouer beaucoup
dans sa popularité parce qu'elle a un
sens de l'humour très très acide ah
mange pas ses mots quand dit quelque
chose qu'en réplique à certaines
personnes donc ça je pense que puis ce
serait très comique donc je pense que ça
contribue un exemple parmi tant d'autres
mais après il y a des contre-exemples
c'est loud et pas tant que ça sur les
réseaux sociaux puis il y avait combien
de personnes
il y en avait beaucoup donc
sa carrière va bien je pense il y a pas
trop à se plaindre il y a pas besoin de
se vendre non c'est sa musique qui parle
d'elle-même il parle il parle beaucoup
de lui-même dans ses chansons donc je
pense qu'il y a aussi une manière de se
bâtir une carrière sans trop miser sur
les réseaux sociaux il faut surtout pas
que ça ça paraisse forcément
on a l'impression d'avoir un accès à ce
qu'elle est vraiment mais il y en a
d'autres pour qui on sent tout le
travail pour ça le sang la sueur
derrière se pose le pied c'est là où
c'est ça fonctionne moins c'est moins
heureux c'est vrai puis souvent ça
paraît même ça fait l'effet contraire
moi j'ai une question pour toi parce que
j'avais un séminaire de maîtrise à
l'Université puis on parlait du
j'ai fait en littérature ah oui OK puis
on parlait justement littéraire puis on
a reçu le j'oublie son nom mais on a
reçu un journaliste qui venait nous
parler de qui ce journaliste culturel
puis viennent nous parler de comment lui
c'est important pour lui garder une
distance entre ce que c'est Christian
des belles
non je pense pas
vraiment bien que je m'en rappelle mais
puis nous parler à quel point c'est
important de garder une distance entre
le milieu artistique puis
le critique culturel pour éviter de
pouvoir rester franc dans ses critiques
mais pas se sentir impliqué dans le truc
puis là tu parles de faire des entrevues
avec des artistes faire une entrevue il
faut que tu te rends quand même
pas aimable mais quand même amical faut
que faut pas être antipathique être
agréable pour pouvoir sortir le meilleur
de tes entrevues puis parallèlement à ça
comme juste la journée où est-ce que
demain écrit en me disant
sa tante au podcast ouais vraiment mais
cette journée-là c'était la journée qui
sortait la critique du spectacle de
Jérémie demain là je me suis dit que
c'est ton ami mon ami on leur suit une
fois que j'ai parlé de ma vie c'était ça
mais moi je me suis dit
Jérémy demain probablement que ça a été
entre pas de te parler mettons le type
parler de toi ou du moins
collaboré avec toi c'est ça exact sauf
que sauf que en même temps ton travail
c'est aussi d'aller à la rencontre des
artistes puis des fois tu te lis
d'amitié avec pas d'amitié mais tu te
lis de sympathie avec un artiste dans
une entrevue qui va peut-être falloir
qu'après ça si tu aimes pas son album tu
n'aimes pas son album c'est quoi ta
posture donc c'est sûr que le contexte
québécois le contexte médiatique
québécois dans les choses particulières
parce que bon on est un peu on est un
grand peuple mais on est peu nombreux on
est un petit peu on n'est pas un petit
peu
de personnes
donc petit milieu tout le monde se
connaît il y a quelque chose de
forcément incestueux là-dedans puis moi
dans mon travail je suis appelé donc
comme tu le dis faire des entrevues avec
des gens ce qui suppose un certain degré
d'intimité qui va être bref qui est très
circonscrit dans le temps mais qui
existe quand même quand ça se déroule
bien
après il y a plein de manières de
prévenir ça dans le sens où dans le
meilleur des mondes mettons qu'un
humoriste sort son spectacle mais là
quand c'est possible c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'il y a comme un paquet de
raisons aussi de nature contextuelle
circonstanciel et économique autour de
ça c'est à dire que lorsqu'on humoriste
donc sort un spectacle idéalement c'est
qu'elle c'est pas la même personne qui
fait l'entrevue au sujet du spectacle
avant la première et la critique parce
que ça te met dans une drôle de poster
c'est pas toujours possible ça m'est
arrivé de faire l'entrevue et d'aller
faire la critique par la suite puis bon
c'est sûr que
ça nous met dans des dispositions
particulières après faut garder en tête
que la personne à qui notre travail
s'adresse en premier lieu c'est pas
l'artiste qui est sur scène c'est notre
lecteur notre lectrice c'est à eux qu'il
faut dire la vérité puis dire c'est quoi
ce spectacle est-ce que c'est bon c'est
pas bon est-ce que c'est moyen qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans dans ce choix
mais c'est ça idéalement bon il y a
d'autres contextes médiatiques ou bon
aux États-Unis par exemple ou je pense
qu'on va tenter de créer une sorte de
demeure plus étanche entre les gens qui
font la critique puis les gens parce
qu'il y a aussi que
je suis appelé à faire des
des entrevues avec des gens lorsqu'ils
lancent de nouvelles oeuvres puis là on
reçoit des communiqués il y a des
relations leur écrit tout ça est
organisés mais il y a aussi que des fois
j'entends parler de quelque chose parce
que j'ai des contacts dans le monde de
l'édition dans le monde littéraire dans
le monde de la musique puis là les gens
ils vivent des affaires puis
soudainement ça fera un bon article dans
le journal puis je leur dis ce que tu
accepterais de me raconter ça puis c'est
venu à mes oreilles parce que je suis en
contact avec mon milieu comme les
journalistes politiques ils font pas
juste retranscrire ce qui reçoivent pas
communiquer évidemment c'est parce que
ils ont des contacts parlent des gens
plus soudainement oh je viens de trouver
quelque chose je viens de gratter un
scoop ici puis je viens de gratter un
scandale donc ça aussi nous sert donc il
faut je pourrais pas je ferai vraiment
mal ma job de journalistes culturel si
je restais puis je parlais à ça je peux
pas dire que je suis en train d'écrire à
des artistes constamment pour leur dire
quelque chose à me raconter de je sais
pas là mais c'est pas ça sauf que je
parle à des gens régulièrement qui
parfois vont avoir envie de me dire des
choses puis c'est le cas de tous mes
collègues à la presse très certainement
donc effectivement c'est difficile mais
pour revenir à Jérémy demain je
comprends que lui aurait peut-être des
réticences à me parler mais moi ça me
dérangerait pas je serai je serai à
l'aise de faire une autre vue avec lui
j'imagine j'irai peut-être une petite
tension peut-être qu'il y a des choses
dans son spectacle que j'ai trouvé
vraiment déplorable tu tiens des propos
avec lesquels je suis j'ai pas juste le
commentaire de mon spectacle était pas
seulement de nature esthétique aussi des
propos qui tiennent dans son spectacle
qui me semble un peu dommage pour pour
dire le moins mais je serai à l'aise en
tout cas je serai ça me dérangerait pas
qu'il se trouve devant moi puis on peut
je pense qu'on pourrait avoir une
conversation en tout cas il est pas sur
une blacklist personnel donc aussi ça
c'est à dire que
mon travail c'est pas de parler
seulement de
que j'ai apprécié de toute façon parfois
dans le cas d'un spectacle du mot il y a
pas moyen de le savoir avant d'y aller
puis mon travail non plus c'est pas
seulement de parler avec des artistes
que j'aime je pense que des fois il y a
une confusion quand par exemple je gère
avec des gens qui étudient ou qui
veulent devenir journaliste culturel il
pense que leur travail c'est seulement
de parler des œuvres qui les rendent
enthousiastes et puis c'est vrai que ça
c'est une part du travail qui est le fun
mais moi à force de le faire ce métier
là ce dont je me suis rendu compte c'est
il y a comme pas vraiment de corrélation
entre les bonnes histoires puisqu'il
fait en fait c'est de raconter une bonne
histoire puis c'est avoir une
conversation avec je sais pas Patrick
Norman en fait j'ai rien contre la
musique de Patrick normand puis je
l'aime de plus en plus plus d'écho son
œuvre mais a priori c'est peut-être pas
le genre de musique que j'aurais écouté
c'était pas le genre de musique que
j'aimais quand j'étais ado mais quelques
mois j'ai fait de mon truc Patrick
Norman puis c'était passionnant parce
que le monsieur a une carrière immense
des richesses de connaissances de
musique il y a une grande passion qui
est palpable donc ça ça va donner ça
peut parce que si je fais bien mon
travail ça va donner un bon article
parce que cette personne là elle est
intéressante mais est-ce que ça veut
dire que Patrick Norman soudainement mon
artiste préféré de tous les temps pas
forcément puis après un jeune Ben qui
vient dans un album que je vais écouter
en boucle à la maison ça va peut-être
pas donner un super texte parce que ces
gens-là ont pas encore grand chose à
dire ils viennent juste de lancer leur
album donc on va leur donner une chance
puis on leur parle peut-être un petit
peu plus tard donc il y a pas c'est ça
l'apprentissage ça ça a été un des
apprentissages majeurs de de ma petite
carrière c'est que le lien entre ce qui
va donner un bon article puis la qualité
de l'oeuvre et des fois il y en a un
puis évidemment c'est plus agréable de
mettre en lumière des choses qui sont
intéressantes que le contraire sauf que
le lien est pas direct mais est-ce que
ça ce que des fois ça m'est arrivé de
de censuré dans le sens que mettons que
tu es con un album
de faire une critique juste pas en
parler plutôt que de donner mais ça
arrive ça veut dire qu'on fait toujours
des choix puis par exemple tu es en
musique ou en littérature c'est les
principaux domaines de ce que c'est la
musique la littérature puis l'humour en
humour ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit un
journal comme la presse puis c'est le
cas à peu près tous les médias au Québec
vont couvrir les premières puis c'est
souvent des artistes bon Jérémy demain
j'ai pas Joe Cormier Louis Morrison va
faire une première à cet automne
Louis José on va la première puis on
découvre si c'est bon ou pas en même
temps que tout le monde puis
on va découvrir parce que ce sont des
personnes connues puis faut absolument
être là mais dans le cas de la musique
tellement de parution sa même affaire en
littérature donc il y a des évidences
puis je pense pas que la presse
pourraient se permettre de pas faire les
critique du nouvel album des Foo
Fighters
de pirate mais c'est ici un jeune
artiste qui lance un album
dont à peu près personne parle
présentement c'est sûr que je vois pas
comme aller le sortir de la pile juste
pour dire que
l'album de Joe blow que vous avez pas
c'est qui c'est vraiment pas bon écoutez
ce recueil de poésie
bon et voilà donc vous voyez là où je
vais en venir on se force pas pour
trouver des parce que c'est ce que je
suis pas facile en fait de trouver des
mauvais projet
donc là si je parle d'un nouvel artiste
la partie ça c'est parce que c'est
quelque chose qui dans lequel je vois ça
veut pas dire que c'est parfait ça veut
pas dire que je vais donner 10 ou 9 sur
10 mais il y a quand même quelque chose
là-dedans qui m'apparaît intéressant
puis dire que de mention puis je veux
partager mon mon enthousiasme auprès de
nos lecteurs puis nous lectrices mais
c'est ce paquet un certain nombre
d'évidence des des artistes qui
s'imposent des oeuvres qui s'imposent à
côté desquels on peut absolument pas
passer parce que sinon les gens vont
dire que c'est qu'il se passe avec la
presse pourquoi
mais après bon il y a d'autres choses
qu'on peut éviter c'est pas nécessaire
de dire du mal de gens que qu'on sait
pas c'est qui de toute façon on peut les
laisser essayer de s'améliorer
déjà été pris dans la position que il y
a un album dont tu dois faire les
critiques de quelqu'un que
personnellement tu apprécié puis qui est
un devenu mettons un ami ou une bonne
connaissance puis que l'autre était
obligé d’école articles puis de dire
j'ai vraiment pas aimé non pas vraiment
mais je dirais pas que j'ai il y a des
gens qui que j'apprécie puis que je
connais un peu plus dans dans le monde
culturel mais j'ai pas vraiment dit il y
a personne avec qui euh
texte pour aller prendre une bière sur
une base régulière il y a des gens dont
je suis un peu plus proche puis je pense
que dans ce cas-là tout ce que je ferais
c'est que je m'abstiendrai de faire CGT
j'ai été recherché par exemple pour
Vincent Vallières quelques années
lorsqu'il y a une émission a ici musique
puis on n'est pas des on n'est pas des
meilleurs hots mais je l'apprécie
[Musique]
de faire une entrevue avec lui mais je
ferais pas une critique de son album
parce que je me sentirais mal puis
j'aurais moi-même l'impression d'être en
conflit d'intérêt donc on comprend que
tu as pas aimé son dernier album
c'est des maisons il y a des mesures à
prendre pour s'assurer que j'ai des
collègues qui pourront parler du
prochain album de Vincent Vallières et
comme tu dis c'est ça c'est un milieu
tellement
petit mon frère mon frère un peu vécu
genre de de situation c'est lui dans le
monde cinéma
podcast destinément qui s'appelle point
de vue où il parle de cinéma québécois
est arrivé que mon frère quelqu'un de
très extrêmement critique dans la vie ça
c'est une autre chose les artistes sont
souvent les critiques les plus affaires
de leur propre travail du travail des
autres donc c'est ça quand il nous
reproche de l'être trop de même d'être
trop à ça j'ai souvent le goût de la
répliquer mais je me souviens de la fois
que tu me parlais d'un tel que tu me dis
ce que tu pensais vraiment ton album
ça j'ai expérimente parce que je fais la
musique dans des discussions de Vannes
des fois c'est c'est c'est
on est pas tout le temps gentil
des fois j'en ai retape petit c'est pas
bon puis c'est psy et puis c'est normal
parce que tu deviens
quand tu es
vraiment pour toi ce que tu fais ni
faiblement tu deviens extrêmement
critique de ton peu de travail tu as
certains idéaux sur lesquelles tu veux
tendre peut-être rapproché peut-être
certains
héros qui étaient certaines musiques qui
écoutent qui qui comme des qui qui
devient un peu les gens justement vidéo
puis
tu crées un genre de
d'échelle personnelle de goût puis de
qu'est-ce qui est bon puis de critères
pour y arriver tu as cru quand tu
écoutes d'autre chose qui restaient qui
est pas dans cette esthétique là qui est
pas dans cette
les gens qui qui aiment leur travail et
qui disent moi quand j'écoute ma musique
ou quand j'ai pas je lis une mes
articles
je vois que des qualités là-dedans c'est
soit des gens qui sont vraiment très
équilibrés qui sont très zen qui doit
faire du yoga qui doivent consulter
peut-être qu'ils font tous ceux qui
mangent bien ou c'est des gens qui
s'illusionnent c'est à dire que c'est
pas moi quand je dis pisse c'est pas
nécessaire d'être abusivement critique
de son propre travail puis de se
fouetter puis te dire il y a un
équilibre à trouver là-dedans puis je
suis déjà allé dans l'excès contrats
puis je pense que maintenant que ma vie
est remplie d'autres choses comme avoir
un enfant ça me permet aussi c'est ça
exactement relativiser c'est c'est le
mot essentiel ici mais
si tu regardes ton truc quand je relis
des vieux articles mais c'est sûr que je
vois juste les défauts mais après les
gens qui écoutent des chansons ou qui
lisent mes articles j'imagine que ils
sont pas constamment en train de scruter
notre travail c'est où là la virgule je
pourrais trouver qui aurait dû être à
l'autre place
ton propre écriture puis peut-être un
certain
standards élevé à certains niveaux mais
là il faut que peut-être que tu lis une
critique
ça doit t'arriver de trouver que c'est
mal écrit aussi je trouve que le travail
de tous mes collègues est absolument
exceptionnel
mais bref pour venir à l'histoire de mon
frère
il fait du cinéma dans la vie et
à temps partiel critique dans son
podcast parce qu'il parle de décidément
c'est au début mon phrase c'est pas
quelqu'un que la langue dans sa poche
puis quand il y a une opinion qui est
passionné puis il y a des femmes puis
quelqu'un qui aime pas quelque chose il
aime pas quelqu'un qui aime quelque
chose
c'est arrivé qui parle de film québécois
et puis disent ça c'est pas très bon
pour telle tête raison
de la productrice ou de ou de du
réalisateur directement puis c'est comme
mène ça m'a fait de la peine ce que te
dit puis nanana
puis aussi c'est non seulement la
personne personnellement qui te fait de
la peine mais aussi c'est le lui c'était
quand même un c'était pas à heure de
grande écoute dans ce que c'est son
podcast puis genre c'est vraiment juste
décidément
toute une industrie qui rêvait à ça il y
a plein de gens qui dépendent du succès
de de un tel de son show du mot de son
album décider ça faciles des fois c'est
comme tu
tu peux par la bande en voulant juste
exprimer ton opinion même
prendre conscience qu'on a une
responsabilité qui est importante je
veux pas la dire que les plus
importantes que les réellement dans le
sens où bon ce n'est que j'aime quand
même rappeler aux gens que ce n'est
qu'un article dans le journal donc pour
reprendre l'exemple de Jérémy demain
j'ai gagné sa tournée se poursuit sa
carrière n'est pas terminée je pense que
les choses vont quand même aller bien
pour lui peu importe ce que j'ai pu
écrire à son sujet mais faut quand même
être conscient que il y a une
responsabilité les mots ils viennent
avec une responsabilité puis il faut
prendre en considération qui peut avoir
des répercussions donc il faut quand
même bien soupeser chacun des mots mais
tout en tout en ayant conscience que la
responsabilité principale c'est de dire
la vérité de ce qu'on pense réellement
de livrer notre propre analyse de
l'oeuvre qui se trouve devant nous c'est
la seconde que tu le fais pas vraiment
c'est là que tu parles la confiance de
tes lecteurs oui ben aussi la question
que je me pose en écrivain un texte
est-ce que ce que je dis ici la qualité
que j'attribue ou le défaut que
j'attribue à une œuvre est-ce que je
suis capable de le défendre correctement
donc ce que je suis capable d'argumenter
plus dans la Ford je pense que lorsque
j'essaie de répondre oui il faut que je
réponde oui à cette question là pour
l'écrire mais après je dis ça mais on
fait notre travail relativement
rapidement donc c'est j'écris un texte
sur un spectacle d'humour
ça va je prends j'ai pas trois quatre
cinq heures ça dépend c'est quand le
deadline s'il faut que mon texte soit
remis le soir si mon texte doit être mis
le soir même le j'écris pendant le show
ça c'est plus le cas des spectacle de
musique en humour on se donne on publie
le lendemain matin parfois on a un petit
peu plus de temps justement pour laisser
macérer le spectacle en nous mais faut
quand même livrer un texte assez
rapidement donc ça aussi ça crée une
sorte de marche d'erreur avec laquelle
il faut apprendre à travailler puis qui
apprend à considération quand on lit ce
genre de texto ça veut ça excuse pas des
des erreurs ou
mais un mauvais travail sauf que il y a
quand même ces conditions là qui sont à
l'oeuvre lorsqu'on produit ce genre de
texte là
moi j'ai j'ai une fascination pour la
les personnes qui sont capables de
vraiment je ne fascination c'est
vraiment pas la bonne impression je
pense pas à tous les jours là mais
le matin puis c'est la première chose à
laquelle il pense d'avoir un opinion
vraiment tranchée sur des affaires moi
je sais j'ai vraiment la difficulté à
le gars qui fait Denis
musical le plus célèbre au monde
puis voyez pas capable de défendre
toutes ces points de vue sur toutes les
plaques tout le temps genre
il va pas genre jouer dans la nuance
habituellement j'ai de la misère à faire
ça c'est vraiment de la misère à
savoir qu'est-ce que j'ai aimé dans
quelque chose si je suis capable de dire
que j'ai aimé quelque chose mais j'ai de
la misère à vraiment trancher mon idée
puis tout ça toujours été dans toi
d'être capable de faire ça ou bien tu le
travail
ma question est claire mais c'est drôle
parce que justement
ce soir là où je suis allé voir Jérémy
ma blonde avait des amis à la maison qui
venaient prendre un verre avec elle puis
donc avant que je quitte pour le
spectacle Les les deux amis de ma blonde
qui me connaissent mais pas tant que ça
me dit mais là tu vas aller prendre le
spectacle tu vas revenir tu vas avoir
comme des tu es capable de décrire ton
opinion d'écrire un texte là-dessus si
je veux dire
mais c'est vrai que quand même quelque
chose de que je comprends qui peut être
un peu je reprends ton mot fascinant
mais je pense que oui là je pense j'ai
toujours eu ce PISA ça sans doute été
nourri par Claude rajote qui lui-même
avait des opinions très tranchées qui
pouvaient faire des destroy qui était il
y avait un côté caricatural là-dedans
mais bon il ménageait pas les albums je
suis sûr que si on faisait ça
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux
les gens grimper dans les rideaux de
l'intimidation sous la forme de critique
musicale pour Pierre des lampes mais
je pense que ça a été aiguisé par par
Claude Raja puis que il y a une part
dîner en moi mais il y a aussi bon c'est
ça je pense que l'équilibre parfois qui
est difficile à trouver puisque j'essaie
de protéger en moi c'est une sorte de
émerveillement c'est un mot un peu kéten
mais tu sais ce qui est guise le regard
du critique c'est d'être exposé à
plusieurs œuvres donc le les spectacles
du mot mal les premières je vais presque
toutes les voir puis j'essaie d'en voir
le plus souvent possible d'aller voir du
rodage puis de m'exposer à toutes sortes
de type d'humoriste pour puis d'en
regarder sur Netflix crave et compagnie
pour avoir une certaine idée de ce qui
se fait présentement puis c'est quoi
l'histoire de l'humour dans quoi cette
nouveau spectacle s'inscrit sauf que là
ce que ça crée ça c'est une sorte de ça
peut créer une sorte de désenchantement
parce que lorsque je vais à la première
bon c'est juste un autre moment dans ma
semaine j'allais voir un spectacle faut
pas être blasé il faut pas devenir blasé
il faut quand même que je prenne en
considération quand j'écris que les gens
qui vont voir le spectacle les autres
personnes qui vont aller voir le
spectacle eux ont payé pour aller le
voir puis ils sont contents d'aller voir
ils ont choisi cet artiste là
ils sont contents d'y aller puis ils
viennent avec une certaine part de
générosité était ils veulent trouver ça
bon tu achètes pas des billets pour un
choix lui puis ça va être moyen en
tabarouette donc c'est ça je pense qu'il
faut lutter pour ne pas devenir blasé
mais en même temps ce qui fait que je
peux avoir des opinions peut-être un
petit peu plus tranchées ou avoir une
sorte d'assurance et puis je dis pas que
naturellement si grande que ça à mes
opinions mais mais quand même lorsque tu
écris quelque chose dans le journal il
faut que tu y crois c'est que j'envoie
plusieurs donc ça je pense que ça forge
ça sculpte mon regard sur sur une heure
puis est-ce que quand mettons que tu vas
voir un spectacle ou tu écoutes un album
qui est boutuil un livre qui est pas
dans le cadre d'une critique que tu veux
faire est-ce que tu
activement le critique
partout en même après ou non il y a
quand même une part de moi qui mais
c'est pas tant de critiquer mais de
trouver genre le
spin que tu pourrais donner un article
donc des fois
je me dis ah mais quand même j'aurais pu
faire une intrus avec l'auteur puis
blablabla donc là faut quand même que
que je ferme l'interrupteur puis que je
redevienne un simple lecteur mais oui
tantôt le quand je parlais de la machine
à idées il y a quand même
cet aspect là ça travaille toujours en
moi les espèces de petits moteurs qui
constamment tourne puis qui essaie de
trouver la manière de transformer ce qui
se trouve devant ce qui se trouve devant
moi en sujet d'article
par rapport à ton autre question de
comment savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on aime quelque chose aussi
on aime quelque chose puis tu sais je
parlais de discussions de Van un peu
plus tôt une des discussions qui revient
souvent c'est c'est un peu la question
qu'est-ce qui fait que quelque chose est
bon est bon mettons
puis parce que des choses que je trouve
bon que tu trouves pas bon que toi tu
trouves bon puis vice versa puis il y a
des choses extrêmement
[Musique]
populaire que je trouve extrêmement
mauvais puis on a des exemples à ce que
j'en aimerais pas mais il y a des
exemples ici ou partout
que je comme
rien contre la personne je trouve que
c'est une super belle et bonne personne
mais je comprends pas l'engouement puis
je comprends pas pourquoi cette personne
là c'est pas la faire de jalousie
je comprends pas pourquoi que autant de
monde partout ce que ces personnes le
voient parce que moi je regarde les
textes les qualités de la musique je
fais comme je
vois aucun intérêt
mais je pense que la question du goût
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le bon goût et le
mauvais goût je suis vraiment loin
d'être un spécialiste de cette question
là mais c'est lié à des questions de
classe sociale d'origine de culture de
race de genre donc faut quand même
prendre ça consolation je pense que la
critique comme beaucoup changé au cours
des je sais pas 10 15 20 dernières
années peut-être au Québec mais aussi au
plan international parce que on prend
ces choses là on considération tu
regardes un site comme pitch fork qui
est comme une des références en matière
de critique musicale puis dans la
première année il est il permettait
d'écrire des textes
qui étaient non seulement affirme qui
était violent qui était vraiment méchant
qui était parfois misogyne ou qui avait
une espèce d'aspect raciste dont le
l'auteur le critique était peut-être pas
tout à fait conscient mais qui était
néanmoins visible pour les gens qui
appartenaient à la communauté dont il
était question
donc toutes ces choses-là qu'entre en
ligne de compte ça veut pas dire que
toutes les œuvres s’équivalent puis que
tout est bon mais faut quand même
prendre conscience que on considère une
oeuvre avec notre propre bagage culturel
qui est lié à notre genre notre classe
sociale notre la culture de laquelle on
vient puis que tout ça va avoir une
influence sur le jugement qu'on peut
poser puis que d'autres personnes vont
poser nos jugements précisément parce
qu'ils viennent d'ailleurs puis aussi
parce que nous on a peut-être pas les
outils pour comprendre c'est ce qui fait
que un site comme Pitchford dont leur
approche souvent de ne publier que des
critiques essentiellement positives mais
c'est parce qu'avant il y a aussi ça qui
une des raisons pour lesquelles avait
plus de critiques négatives à une
certaine époque je pense que il y avait
ce qu'on appelait le critique
généraliste et puis je correspond quand
même pas mal à ça mais c'est rare que je
vais faire des critiques qui
appartiennent à un genre que je connais
pas du tout je connais le rap
correctement mais ça va chez c'est qui
docteur dream
une critique d'un album de rap parce que
je m'y connais pas assez je peux une
expertise assez importante mais avant tu
avais le critique généraliste qui
parlait de tout donc les ramasse un
album de rap il connaît pas ce pantoufle
puis là il dit des choses là-dessus qui
sont peut-être intéressantes parce qu'un
regard frais mais qui sont probablement
juste à côté de la traque parce que
c'est ça il s'y connaît pas suffisamment
donc le pitchwork maintenant va engager
des gens qui si c'est un album de de
doux métal il y a le gars de doux métal
qui va faire avec ce type de médaille et
même chose pour le Ravi pour tous les
autres gens musicaux donc ça crée
peut-être des textes qui sont plus
nuancés mais on peut penser que ça crée
des textes qu'on enracinés dans
davantage de connaissances et puis de
contexte puis c'est ça qu'il faut pas
perdre de vue non plus c'est que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui rapprochent à la
critique musicale notamment la critique
littéraire aussi d'être dans une espèce
de
d'être un peu mièvre là autour d'être
toujours au centre le 3 étoiles trois
étoiles et demi et c'est aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup d'oeuvres qui méritent
les chefs
[Musique]
de pirate tantôt mais si bravo musée qui
lance un album j'imagine qu'ils vont
quand même s'être assuré que ça a une
certaine qualité ça veut pas dire que
c'est forcément une grande oeuvre ça se
peut lance un album poche ça se peut
qu'une maison d'édition prestigieuse au
Québec lance un mauvais livre mais
c'est la même chose avec les humoristes
avant que les humoristes arrivent sur
scène et on fait des dizaines et des
dizaines sinon des centaines de dates de
rodage ce qui fait que dans la salle les
gens de faire du temps vont rire lors de
la première c'est les blagues ont été
testées elles sont éprouvés mais après
bon il peut arriver certaines choses
comme il y a aussi ça c'est à dire que
la job du critique c'est de parler
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la qualité
de l'oeuvre est-ce que c'est bon ou pas
ce qui est effectivement très très
subjectif mais c'est aussi de mettre en
contexte de dire bon ce spectacle
s'inscrit dans tel phénomène dans telle
lignée ça fait penser à ceci ceci ceci
puis l'humoriste tient tel genre de
propos son regard sur la société puis
sur la vie c'est ceci et cela puis c'est
là moi ou souvent je me permets d'être
le plus en fait non seulement je me
permets mais je pense que c'est
essentiel d'être
peut-être un petit peu plein incisif
parce que même si les humoristes ne font
que des blagues des fois ils cherchent
toutes sortes de préjugés petit arétique
c'est là où je peux mais tu as un
spectacle raté le ou un disque pas bon
ça me met pas en colère le dire les
artistes ont vraiment le droit puis je
peux répéter de se tromper d'essayer
quelque chose puis que ça fonctionne pas
c'est l'endroit le plus stress c'est pas
si grave que ça on ne joue pas assez de
soi bon ça peut être un peu plus grave
dans le sens où tu as peut-être payer 60
pièces pour ça mais c'est rare que les
spectacles du monde je le redis sont
catastrophiques mais black misogyne
c'est une blague
besoin de le dire et de le souligner
voir de le dénoncer je comprends ouais
je comprends
je comprends mettez
-moi l'exemple du spectacle de Jérémy
demain il fait beaucoup dans le
dans le genre de service
et puis genre pour toi probablement pour
des gens qui écoutent ça c'est un peu
des phrases des un peu des formules
toutes faites un peu lancé comme ça sans
trop fondre de fondement puis
il y a peut-être des gens qui étaient là
qui c'est la première fois qui entendait
cette phrase là puis que ça mon dieu ça
tombait éveiller quelque chose donc ça
ça me met pas trop en colère c'est
davantage ce qu'on évoquait à l'instant
les contradictions dans ses propos puis
des propos qui m'apparaissent plutôt
enraciné dans des stéréotypes ça ça
me ça peut ça peut me choquer davantage
mais
des clichés il y en a dans toutes les
heures puis oui ça se peut que je
l'écrive mais ça va pas me mettre dans
une grande colère non plus
à chaque fois que j'essaie de
discussions là c'est comme si l'oeil est
toujours un peu genre de deux camps qui
se forme le camp de ceux qui disent non
mais nous on est musicien on sait on a
étudié la musique on écoute la musique
on connaît de la musique donc notre goût
est plus aiguisé raffiné que la personne
qui coupe pas vraiment de musique qui
donc on a plus entre guillemets là je
caricature mais je simplifie mais on a
plus en guillemets raison quand on dit
que ça c'est bon que ça c'est pas bon
que la personne qui a aucune culture
musicale puis là moi je suis toujours la
personne qui dit oui mais personne qui
écoute et que ça retisse qu'elle aime
que ça fait du bien
voir c'est chaud
il y a personne qui a tort mais ton cœur
parle Ton cœur n'a pas tort si tu aimes
tel artiste tu l'aimes c'est aussi
simple que ça donc je pense que c'est
impossible de trancher ce débat là dans
le sens où personne a raison les gens
qui vont aller voir Nickelback au Centre
Bell dans quelques semaines
j'imagine qu'ils vont pas en se disant
aux États-Unis
au cégep université parce que j'étais en
harlelette littérature
c'est un peu l'ennemi numéro 1 dans
ouais puis c'est encore mieux
les premiers albums de Nico back ça
rentre quand même genre c'est moi en
tout cas personnellement ils ont fait
des bonnes tonnes
joue à chaume moi je lève le son là
j'arrive moi
je vais signer une critique négative
d'un journal il y a quelqu'un qui va
sortir l'extrait de ce gars là au zéro
il lève le son qu'en école bac joue à
chaume et voilà j'aurais dû je me
rappelle d'un souper de
facultés de facultés un super avec les
gens de profil littérature ce genre
d'Arnaud où est-ce que j'étais le seul à
dire ok si c'est nul à chier de même là
c'est qui qui était c'est plein
d'Abraham pour remplir les plaines
d'avant c'est qui tout de ce monde là
tout du monde qui ont qui sont cadres
sur des imbéciles qui savent pas c'est
quoi qui est bon parce qu'on entend tout
le monde autour de la table si parler
c'est le pire groupe de l'univers tu
sais non mais c'est parce que aussi
c'est tout à fait naturel d'associer
le goût des gens ce que les gens aiment
à ce qu'ils sont profondément mais puis
je pense qu'il peut avoir un lien pour
présenter une sorte de profil
sociologique du fan de Nicole bac mais
il y a peut-être pas de lien non plus
entre ces deux affaires là puis
peut-être que les gens qui aiment
l'école back parce que c'est de la
musique qui est festive je pense que
c'est de la musique qui est présente
qu'on entend la radio donc qui est
aisément accessible
donc il y a plein de raisons qui nous
mènent jusqu'à un artiste puis qui sont
pas forcément liés à une grande
réflexion chez ces personnes là qui sont
nécessairement lié non plus alors valeur
mais vous voyez ça c'est ça ça
m'intéresse vraiment c'est le genre de
un texte que j'avais lu avec examen un
article c'est un journaliste dans
Green l'ancien site de Bill Smith
exactement qui qui est allé voir je
pense que il est allé voir dans la même
soirée un spectacle de Creed et de
Nicole back parce que dans la ville où
se trouvait
de raconter de parler mais qui sont ces
gens qui vont voir les deux groupes rock
les plus détestés les plus méprisés au
monde ça donne un texte super
intéressant je sais pas si je devrais le
dire ici mais j'ai le projet puis je
veux faire ça bientôt de groupe j'ai vu
passer sur les réseaux sociaux il y a un
groupe dans les Laurentides tu me trompe
pas qui est en groupe hommage en école
donc c'est pas juste une école bac c'est
groupe hommage à des goldback puis ça
m'aide dégueu c'est pas gentil j'ai
aucune raison de penser qu'ils sont pas
j'aimerais vraiment je veux les
interviewer les rencontrer puis aller
voir un spectacle comprendre comment
un petit peu non seulement parce que
fonder une chose c'est pas que ça va
devenir
un gros pommage et on va se promener
partout au Québec pour jouer la chanson
ça ça m'intéresse
je reviens ce que je disais tantôt
j'écouterai pas à part les moments où ça
joue à chaud je lève le son mais
j'écoute pas d'une école bac mais ça je
trouve ça m'intéresse ça ça me passionne
comme sujet je veux j'aimerais ça aller
au fond de cette affaire c'est en plus
j'aimerais que tu le fasses que je
puisse lire ce reportage là parce que
c'est sûr que ça va être le parté
partout est-ce qu'ils vont aux autres là
où il y a du monde qui viennent
je pense ça doit ça doit ressembler
rock la petite grenouille
il y a des bières qui se boit c'est des
points dans les airs effectivement mais
ça c'est l'influence de ça votre joint
de pH pensé l'influence de hunterest
Thompson aussi comment je peux aller
dans un milieu
plutôt étranger pour ne pas dire
complètement étranger puis essayer de
voir ce que ça suscept en moi comme une
réaction puis aussi essayer
dans l'empathie la bienveillance
pour vivre mais il y a quand même cette
idée-là le titre sortir de sa zone de
confort pour employer une expression
ouais c'est ça puis de d'aller voir
infiltrer les fans de Nico back c'est le
même combat il y en a qui est un peu
moins dangereux que l'homme mais il y a
quelque chose de cousin effectivement
je veux pilote peut-être que Pascal et
moi pas ça qu'on amène ce qu'on ramène
le selfie
parce que parce que je suis intéressé à
entendre ton opinion sur ce dans le fond
euh
la personne qui qui visait parce qu'on
pourra pas avoir son opinion sur ce
cette histoire là c'est que mon frère
justement que je te parlais qui est
quelqu'un
tu l'aimerais je pense que vous auriez
des des
affinités ça c'est sûr
Pascal plante le tête de jeu s'intéresse
au cinéma
où j'ai de nombreuses lacunes c'est dans
mon règlement je fais des blagues parce
que ça lui passe Gall
je vais aller voir je regarde
si il y a écrit sur Facebook et puis
lui naïvement son facebook privé ça
disait je parle à mes amis que puis mes
amis voient ça
reste entre nous c'est pas il y a pas
5000 amis puis il y a pas bon puis il y
a écrit un poste parce que lui
il trouve que c'est pas comment dire
ça peut paraître comme de l'envie ou de
la jalousie je pense vraiment pas que
c'est ça c'est que
en cinéma
il y a plein de super artistes qui ont
de la misère à avoir du financement pour
faire leur film puis qui ont des projets
incroyables puis il y a selon lui déjà
qui sont des vedettes puis qui
font des films là ont mis un critique
ou ni un succès un festival pas tant non
plus des bons
box-office que ça mais c'est DVD qui ont
des vedettes dans leur film puis
reçoivent des enveloppes énormes pour
faire des projets souvent que
son pôle nécessairement si non plus
impliqué motivant ce projet-là parce que
parce qu'ils sont arrivés un peu comme
un cheveu ça assure à la fin du
processus dans le besoin de réalisateur
on va prendre cette personne là est
connue faire un film
d'annonce ça
puis le point clé de son poste en plus
c'est ce que tu as dit c'est il y a pas
de succès box-office non plus parce que
si l'équation est facile c'est que moi
tu finances des projets que tu en es un
gros nom tu sais que ça va ça va
exploser c'est pas ça non plus
par des sociétés
[Rires]
il était comme un peu pris avec un truc
hors de contrôle en dessous de son de
son poste
puis bref c'est comme les sociétés aussi
des financement comme titre
parce que
on finance ton film on finance de film
là mais si on peut pas s'entrer
mais d'un côté
les institutions de financement dans la
mesure où elles sont publiques il y a
tout à fait le droit de recevoir de
l'argent de ces gens-là et de les
critiquer Pierre Falardeau faisait
on pourrait aussi penser puis entre
Pierre Falardeau lui-même le pensait que
ses opinions politiques lui ont nuit
dans les subventions qui recevaient ou
pas pour créer ses films évidemment les
gens concernés ni catégoriquement que
c'était le cas mais
on peut penser qu'il y avait peut-être
un peu de ça puis qu'au moment de
choisir entre la personne qui a dit
qu'on était des moutons ou qu'on était
des idiots d'un journal puis l'autre
personne on va peut-être y aller avec
l'autre personne
mais est-ce que tu veux que je dise que
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je dise au
sujet de ton frère c'est une bonne idée
de la controverse autour de Pascal c'est
que j'aurais aimé avoir ton opinion sur
cette situation là en particulier c'est
pourquoi est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce que des personnes qui
justement qui comme rien à table de
conversation sont financés c'était comme
incompréhensible pour moi encore parce
que je vois le poste de passer mes cinq
parts un petit peu de d'intérêt sans les
sans le cas précis le tir puissant parce
que en plus c'est que ce film là avait
fait un genre de scandale qui était pas
du tout nécessaire par le choix
que ça existe ça parce que ça puis même
encore là je peux regarder mais je pense
que il y avait quand même une tentative
de créer un succès au box-office qui
sait pas qui c'est pas réalisé tant que
ça non puis justement mais il y en a eu
un buzz sur ce film-là par l'espèce de
dialogue autour du film puisque je fais
en soi mais je connais vraiment pas
c'est le cinéma québéco pour me
prononcer là-dessus mais je sais que le
cinéma québécois depuis quelques années
de la difficulté à renouer avec les
grands succès du box-office qui qui ont
commencé à émerger autour des boys à peu
près puis il y en a eu plusieurs dans
les années qui ont suivi pilote depuis
ce moment-là il y a des gens qui
essaient de recréer ses succès là sans
sans trop y arriver puis sinon les films
qui font des meilleures performances au
box-office il me semble que c'est des
films qui justement ont certains succès
critiques alors que
d'un côté les films qui vont se faire
plutôt ramassés par la critique puis
ceux qui vont faire et qui vont avoir du
succès et les films vont faire la
tournée des festivals qui seront
célébrités par la critique et que
personne va aller voir ça mais mais
ouais
c'est plus difficile pour quelques
années pour qu'ils viennent dire mettons
qu'on continue là-dessus ça en dit long
je trouve quand même sur
je peux loin de moi l'idée de remettre
en question de diminuer le travail des
critiques maintenant
mais je fais des blagues mais n'empêche
que les critiques que cinéma ou de
musique ou de peu importe et un type de
personne
psychologique de profil sociologique du
fan de nicolback mais c'est clair qu'un
profil sociologique de la personne qui
devient critique de cinéma de me dire
oui tout à fait puis c'est là où j'en
reviens à nos angles morts aussi c'est à
dire que effectivement que je suis
devenu critique journaliste culturel
pour un certain homme un certain nombre
de raisons qui forgent mon goût à moi ce
que je recherche dans une oeuvre puis
que c'est peut-être pas la même chose
que tout le monde recherche ok après
c'est quand même moi qui crie le texte
donc il faut que je parle de mon point
de vue à moi mais il une sorte de
manière aussi de dire directement ou de
suggérer au lecteur que ceci est
davantage mon opinion à moi puis je suis
conscient que ce ne sera pas peut-être
l'opinion tout le monde et que quelqu'un
d'autre trouvera dans ceci matière à
réflexion matière à rire matière à
s'amuser se divertir alors que moi je
n'y ai trouvé que de l'ennui il y a
plein de manières de dire ça mais après
on peut pas mettre toujours mettre
toutes les nuances nécessaires puis un
texte ça peut pas être une série de
notes en mode page en disant ceci n'est
que mon opinion etc ça donne pas les
plus intéressants au monde mais on ne
parle toujours que de son propre point
de vue c'est super tout le monde qui
fait de la critique culturelle du
journaliste culturel gagnerait je pense
que la part des gens sont conscients
mais on gagne à garder ça en tête
lorsqu'on on écrit un texte
c'est la chose que si je me répète
ce qu'on aime ce qu'on aime pas
finalement c'est comme tu le disais le
truc dans Star et puis que si je me mets
à dire quelque chose est vraiment la
pure merde c'est comme si ouais comme si
je dis que c'est comme si tu t'insultes
tout un pan de la population qui
est différente toi effectivement que les
respecter essayer de trouver une manière
de bouger d'apprécier mais de respecter
mettons les différents
artistes ou les différents styles
différents
à respecter la différence finalement
tout à fait puis c'est rare parce que
surtout quand on assiste à con on écoute
un disque parfois un peu moins mais
quand tu vas voir un spectacle
ça m'arrive avant
de d'être journaliste culturel j'allais
pas voir de spectacle d'artistes que
j'aime pas mais le des fois ça arrive
puis c'est quand même rare ça peut se
produire mais c'est rare que tu vas voir
un artiste qui est comme beaucoup de
succès puis tu sors de là en disant j'ai
aucune idée pourquoi cette personne là
on arrive quand même à identifier ou à
comprendre avant une sorte de
compréhension de ce qui fait cette
personne là rejoint autant de gens des
fois c'est parce que cette personne là
s'adresse à ce qu'il y a de plus ville
quoi de plus Nono c'est son public ça ça
existe mais parfois aussi c'est parce
que cette personne là un relation le
bâti une relation avec son public bien
comprendre son public d'une manière qui
est très très intime qui pour nous
semble complètement étrangère parce
qu'on n'est pas familier avec ce monde
là puis il faut effectivement pas perdre
ça de vue parce que ça peut devenir
si je dis que ton bain préféré pas bon
c'est sûr que ça va l'impression que
personnelle
alors que il y a pas forcément de lien
tout seul
[Musique]
c'est quoi des sujets qui apportent le
bain de nicobag dommage à Nickelback qui
habite que tu auras envie de faire dans
le futur
si tu veux pas à moins que tu vas pas
brûler les te donner les idées à
d'autres personnes qui pourraient
écouter ça en fait pas de ouais
c'est drôle parce que je parle avec un
collègue qui me disait que une autre
époque un autre journal et il fallait
absolument pas que tu c'est pas le cas
du tout à la presse puis je peux parler
de mes idées avec mes collègues sans
craindre qui veulent me les voler mais
elle me parle de nos jours là un autre
journal un autre époque où il fallait
absolument que tu gardes tes idées pour
toi puis il fallait même pas que tu
penses trop fort parce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un d'autre qui allait se pointer
dans le même résultat
mais je suis content de pas vivre à
cette époque et dans ce ne pas
travailler pour ce journal mais ce que
j'aime beaucoup puisque je fais depuis
quelques années c'est tenté puis c'est
toujours difficile mais
des gens de me parler quand ils veulent
pas parler
ou retrouver des gens des fois c'est pas
nécessaire de les convaincre c'est juste
que tu dis pourquoi ne pas entendu
parler cette personne-là depuis aussi
longtemps c'est parce que personne l'a
appelé et le tu l'appelles puis cette
personne-là répond à oui je veux parler
ça me fait plaisir plus tu demandes
pourquoi vous avez pas parlé on vous a
pas entendu depuis aussi longtemps parce
que personne m'appelle bon ok c'est ça
mais quand c'est déjà plus connu souvent
c'est parce qu'on prie la décision de ce
que tirer mais j'ai commencé une série à
la presse
est-ce que c'était l'été dernier je
pense qu'elle était dernier qui
s'appelle loin des projecteurs c'est des
entrevues que je fais avec des avec des
gens c'est ceux qui sont c'est pas
vraiment c'est un peu une espèce de spin
sur l'idée du que sont-ils devenus mais
c'est juste que le que sont-ils devenus
des fois c'est on retrouve ces Stef cars
ça m'intéresse pas quoi que ça pourrait
m'intéresser mais j'essaie de faire des
rencontres avec des gens qui ont quand
même qui ont eu un apport culturel
important donc la première personne que
j'ai rencontré cet mari et qu'elle
incarnait la première
qu'on a pas vu depuis un petit moment
puis qui est joué un rôle hyper
important dans mon enfance est-ce que
vous avez été est-ce que vous avez déjà
écouté ça je fais une entrevue puis
c'est toujours intéressant de faire des
entrées ces gens-là parce que de trouver
des moyens de sortir du contexte de la
promo parce que quand on rencontre des
gens qui viennent de lancer un album ils
peuvent être dans de bonnes dispositions
écouter nos questions être de commerce
très agréable mais ils ont quand même un
message à livrer puis on parle d'une
œuvre en particulier on parle de quelque
chose qui est très circonscrit tandis
que donc on a moins le contrôle sur
l'histoire qu'on est en train de
raconter tandis que lorsque je rencontre
ces gens-là dans les contextes qui sont
pas des contextes de promo mais là tu as
toute une heure à considérer puis en
plus de recul puis ils vont davantage de
parler de manière c'est pas juste parce
que
une histoire suive le fil d'une histoire
ça c'est le fun aussi parce que je fais
une entrevue avec
un gars qui s'appelle Harlan qui est le
chanteur de qui chante avec Valère qui
chantent dans le Brooks
je trouve ça très amusant mais son son
époux ce qui était là m'a dit qu'il y
avait l'âge qui pourrait être le père
des gars de valeurs les gars de valeurs
ont l'a mis trentaine donc on devine
quel âge là mais c'est un gars qui vient
de Jacksonville en Floride qui a grillé
ici à Montréal au début des années 90
puis il y avait un certain nombre
d'articles il crée son sujet dans les
médias anglo mais pas vraiment dans les
médias Franco en tout cas c'est peu donc
j'ai eu la chance d'aller chez lui pour
faire un entrevue puis je me m’afouiller
un peu sa carrière puis fait plein de
choses je suis en train de travailler
sur un reportage au sujet du
studio Morin night qui est un studio
hyper important dans les années 80 qui
était à morning fondé par André Perry un
personnage majeur de l'histoire de la
musique au Québec réalisateur
propriétaire de studio des studios
ailleurs mais donc le studio marinade de
police enregistrer là cat Steven
d'enregistrer le plein l'artiste là il
majeur
dans l'histoire de David Bowie
enregistré là
il y a une entrevue avec lui à
au Téléjournal la Radio-Canada avec
patrice Roy patricia est allé chez lui
puis faire une entrevue sur sa carrière
mais la carrière dans une entrevue pour
la télé c'est d'entrevue de fond mais la
carrière d'André Perry est tellement
riche parce que c'est lui qui a
enregistré Gifi cette chance dans la
chambre d'hôtel royal avec la Kyoko
donc il parle de ça il parle un peu de
sous-marin mais en voyant cette entrevue
là je me mets ça crée beaucoup de
réactions donc je constate que les gens
sont intéressés par l'histoire d'André
Perry puis je me mets fouillé sur le
studio marinade je me rends compte il y
a quand même pas mal d'articles qui ont
été écrits mais
tu sais j'ai plein de questions ça aussi
c'est quand même un bon guide ça ça
trompe rarement si moi j'ai des
questions je veux poser des questions
des Perry là-dessus ça veut dire qu'il y
a quelqu'un d'autre je me souviens je
suis une parenthèse mais je me souviens
l'été dernier j'ai fait une entrevue son
homme of session c'est la l'assistante
personnelle de Conan
coanime le podcast de Conan avec lui
c'est le pro douceur du podcast que son
micro son nom puis qu'on a une qui
connaît ensemble puis évidemment il
taquine tous les deux parce que elle
elle arrête pas de dire qu'elle est la
paix assistante personnelle au monde
puis c'est devenu un personnage vraiment
très très drôle puis après
on s'imagine pas que l'assistante puisse
avoir la balle puis la traîne de toutes
sortes de non puis ils sont vraiment
très très amusant puis très
attendrissant et ils sont là mauvreté
lance un livre l'été dernier
moi j'écoute le patiente puis j'aime ça
donc parce que je peux faire une autre
truc si je réussis à la joindre ce que
c'est un bouquiner
aucun problème
je racontais à mon cousin dont je suis
assez proche donc je suis très proche
plus je lui dis hey je fais un autre qui
est ici c'est qui sonne of session je
veux l’impressionner
dans le journal d'entrevue avec son
homovation on s'en fout là à Montréal je
sais pas j'ai l'impression que je te
raconter ça parce que finalement c'est
moi qui avait raison parce que j'écris
mon article puis c'est même mais moi
j'étais moi-même étonné je le faisais
quand même par plaisir personnel puis il
faut aussi s'autoriser ça parfois mais
là c'était quand même une belle preuve
il s'est pas ça fonctionne pas à 100% là
c'est pas mais mais là dans ce cas là
cet article fonctionnait d'une manière
très très étonnante donc
[Musique]
c'est une longue parenthèse pour dire
que j'avais des questions pour rentrer
Perry puis je trouvais pas une réponse
là-dessus donc je suis allé rencontrer
de mon reportage va être mais le avec un
sujet la difficulté avec un sujet comme
le studio warrenheit c'est que il y a
tellement de gens qui sont passés là
depuis tellement de gens à rush j'ai pas
nommé rush enregistré 7 8 plusieurs
albums c'était le lieu où il y a les
systématiquement puis donc là j'ai fait
un truc mais je parle à plein de gens
pour avoir
ajouté une quad puis je pourrais passer
ma vie là-dessus que ça pourrait se
transformer en projet de livre puis
sinon l'autre personne que j'essaie de
me convaincre de de m'accorder une
entrevue puis j'ai essayé de le recevoir
à deviens de suite voulu puis ça a pas
fonctionné donc j'ai fait un autre
épisode un peu différent c'est Julien
minot de mal à la jupe
qui est retiré dans ces terres en
Mauricie depuis un petit moment qui est
encore actif qui réalise des albums avec
plein plein d'artistes québécois mais
qui veut pas parler et puis je lui écris
j'ai fini par faire un autre un épisode
sur l'album trompe-linge de malajub avec
deux autres gars de management voulu
parce que Julien ne voulait pas ne
pouvait pas y participer mais je lui
écris là une fois de temps en temps
salut Julien changer
comme trois jours après je le relance je
préfère attendre d'avoir quelque chose à
présenter pour pour faire des entrevues
donc ouais j'aimerais vraiment ça avoir
l'occasion de je l'ai déjà interview
c'est une des premières personnes que
j'ai interviewé lorsque j'écrivais pour
le journal
à l'Université de Sherbrooke
le collectif mais mais au tabac ça
devait être une mauvaise entrevue parce
que c'est ça parce que je commençais
peut-être
[Rires]
tantôt
c'est toujours ça le défi c'est de
trouver des des sujets qui
ça veut pas dire que parce qu'un sujet
il est dans différents journaux dans
différents médias au même moment c'est
un mauvais sujet puis évidemment que si
Coeur de pirate sur un album on aura
beaucoup parlé de cœur de pirate en
cours de celle-là mais que tout le monde
veut vouloir faire un truc avec elle
pique avoir des choses intéressantes à
dire à chacune de ces personnes là mais
sur le fun aussi de trouver une histoire
qui t'appartient que je vais être le
seul à raconter pour le moment du moins
puis qui qui permettent qui va permettre
à moi de me distinguer de me donner une
couleur particulière qui va permettre au
journal pour lequel je travaille au
média pour lequel je travaille d'avoir
une couleur c'est le fun car les gens
ouvrent leur journal puis que un sujet
je m'attendais pas les gens les gens
vont écouter votre podcasts
sur le studio my night mais sur les
quelques personnes qui ont pas écouté le
podcast
assez souvent recevoir des artistes qui
sont en début de parcours puis qui
c'est quand même devenu une plateforme
importante les podcasts au Québec puis
le vôtre beaucoup de succès puis que
vous receviez une artiste comme Ariane
Roy bon c'est super cool parce que moi
ça m'a permis d'entendre une longue
entrevue avec Ariane Roy ce qui existe
pas beaucoup dans dans les internets
puis
j'imagine qu'il était contente parce que
ça a dû faire connaître sa musique
auprès d'un public qui
ignorait son existence et qui doivent
être contents aujourd'hui parce que leur
vie
meilleure depuis ce moment-là je peux
vous parler d'un ben un nouveau ben
Montréal qui s'appelle la sécurité si
vous attendez
très très bon album j'écoute ça depuis
que l'album depuis que je l'ai reçu puis
c'est sûr que je vais le couper en
boucle
répéter c'est du post-punk mais très
dansant ça ressemble mais ça ressemble
pas tant que ça mais on sent l'influence
des des bififty tous parce que le groupe
américain parce que les cœurs féminins
qui sont très présents guitare angulaire
c'est comme la formulation la formule
classique pour parler de post-paul les
guitares angulaires mais c'est très
dense hein aussi c'est toujours le
toujours le fan de la main moi j'écoute
pas beaucoup de musique c'est sûr qu'il
y a des gens qui sont capables d'écouter
de la musique déprimante puis de pas
être déprimé puis moi il y a des albums
que j'apprécie qui que je considère
comme des chefs mais que je suis juste
pas capable d'écouter parce que ça veut
juste me mettre dans un état trop trop
sombre trop trop noir donc un des albums
comme celui-là qui paraissent ça me rend
heureux parce que parce que je peux
l'écouter en boucle puis danser avec
avec ma chambre agréable c'est vraiment
un très très bon album
sinon ah ben je peux peut-être parler du
t-shirt que je porte dilemme c'est un
je pourrais qualifier sa musique de pop
punk qui joue aussi dans un bain qui
s'appelle lost love qui est plus dans le
power pop mais donc la musique qui vient
clairement du punk mais qui est très
très tourné vers la mélodie puis je
pense je me permets de présumer qui
écoutent un peu de qui connaissent imo
donc ce côté et puis il y a vraiment un
sens donc pour les mélodies qui qui est
assez qui est très admirable puis donc
écoute son album première fois puis la
deuxième fois déjà tu connais toutes les
chansons
donc sont plus récentes album et
excellent c'est en français aussi donc
il y en a quand même assez peu du punk
la sécurité c'est en anglais et en
français mais ce que Guilhem fait en
solo sont plus récente album c'est c'est
strictement en français puis les textes
sont sont bien aussi sont très très bien
sont cool
de qui je pourrais vous parler d'autre
[Musique]
de reportage que j'ai pour que j'ai pour
cet automne parce qu'ils partent en
tournée
[Musique]
je connais depuis pour avoir des côtes
pour l'édition de Vannes pour ton
article je serai dans la vente c'est ça
qui est prévu parce que depuis quelques
années déjà donc Alexandre Martel que tu
connais bon Alexandre Martel qui est le
CHUM de Lou Adrian mais qui est aussi
qui crie avec elle puis ils font tout
ensemble je me permets qui font tout
je vois dans un groupe qui s'appelait
mauve
que j'ai déjà une petite un petit moment
de ma vie où je bouquais des spectacles
à Sherbrooke et puis
j'ai déjà bouquet mauve puis ensuite à
chaque fois que j'allais les voir puis
c'est déjà arrivé à certains moments que
j'étais pas mal la seule personne dans
la salle donc je me suis un peu lié avec
les gars puis c'est pour ça que j'ai pu
demander un peu plus tard à Alexandre de
faire la musique thème de ton podcast de
ce que tu as voulu la reprise de Daniel
Boucher c'est lui et il Adrian qui ont
fait la chanson thème de juste entre toi
et moi qui est vraiment très accroché
j'ai écrit un peu gêné de faire mais je
demande à Alex en premier j'aurais
jamais osé imaginer que l'eau Adrienne
allait participer à la chanson avec lui
je lui donne quelques idées mais alors
précisant bien qu'ils peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent évidemment
le thème de juste entre toi et moi ne
serait-ce que pour ça si le projet ça
avait été juste le thème musical j'avais
déjà été j'ai l'impression de gâcher le
projet en la couleur avec déjà vu un
truc mais donc depuis ce moment-là parce
que Alexandre connaît mon amour pour non
seulement la musique mais pour
l'histoire du journaliste musical puis
bon mon rêve ça a toujours été un effet
préféré ici évidemment en mode famous
qui raconte l'histoire de camion qui
accompagne c'était droite un groupe
fictif le Miss comme un mélange entre
les grosses à tourner avec eux pendant
des mois donc moi ce serait ça mon rêve
mais évidemment que c'est pas tout à
fait possible dans le monde médiatique
dans lequel on vit parce que ça implique
des coups ça implique que si je pars
pendant deux mois qu'un ben je veux
peut-être je vais avoir écrit un article
à la fin c'est pas beaucoup mais
Alexandre connaisse ce rêve là qui
m'habite donc les il m'a écrit récemment
j'ai rencontré finalement Dominique
tardif puis je veux pas qu'il vienne
normal
je pense dans la prochaine semaine tu
vas te rendre compte tu veux savoir ça
vient d'où là
je suis posé de faire un petit bout de
tournée je veux pas toute la tournée
avec vous mais il y a quand même aussi
l'idée d'un moment historique là-dedans
parce que lorsqu'on jouait j'étais là au
Franco puis est-ce que tu étais sur
scène
un moment historique quel fait ça c'est
un des grands spectacles que j'ai vu
dans dans les dernières années c'était
en tout cas moi dans mes souvenirs de
spectacle c'est dans les dans le top
puis il y a aussi c'est à dire que les
albums de tous ces artistes là sont
exceptionnels mais le fait qu'il soit
réuni rinçait encore plus précieux
encore plus exceptionnelle mais ce qui
est d'autant plus touchant c'est que
lorsque je me trouve dans une salle au
chaud de des trois puis le au spectacle
aux Franco l'été dernier
la foule est composée de gens plus
jeunes que que nous trois qui
connaissent les paroles de ces trois
artistes là par cœur donc ils sont hyper
investis dans l'oeuvre de ces trois
artistes là
qui chante en français ce qui est quand
même non négligeable moi ça ça me touche
là d'une certaine manière puis c'est
juste aussi très touchant de voir de
jeunes gens aussi investis dans un
artiste québécois comme moi j'ai été
investi dans l'oeuvre de manager dont on
parlait tantôt mais elles sont vraiment
formidables est-ce que je peux plugger
quelque chose j'ai fait une entre
Alexandre Martel m'a demandé lorsque il
y a lancé son plus récente album sous le
nom Anatole mais l'album
pourquoi faire
quand même ceux qui
m'a il voulait faire donc une longue
entrevue comme il y en avait davantage à
une certaine époque à l'époque de
musique plus donc il m'a demandé si
j'accepterais d'animer ça donc on a
filmé ça c'est disponible sur Youtube ça
s'appelle entrevue numéro 1 parce que
pour rendre les choses encore toutes les
chansons sur son album s'appelle toons 3
mais sont pas dans l'ordre comme la tôle
4 c'est la première puis c'est vrai une
chance que l'album est bon parce que
c'est ça on pourrait lui reprocher à
Alexandre je l'aime beaucoup donc on a
fait cette entrevue là c'est disponible
sur Youtube puis ça c'est mais tous ces
gens là aussi Ariane je connais moi
Ariane mais loi Adrianne Thierry
Alexandre je doute pas que Ariane et ses
qualités là aussi c'est que ils sont une
grande culture musicale puis on sent
qu'il y a un investissement dans ce
qu'ils font qui qui est totale un
investissement sur scène ils savent le
monde dans lequel il s'inscrivent puis
il y a toutes ces raisons là au-delà de
la chanson qui sont irrésistibles dans
mélodie qui sont résistibles de toutes
ces raisons-là qui font que
c'est le fan de les voir aller ben oui
vraiment il y a vraiment sans parler de
leurs accompagnateurs
c'est à cause des accompagnateurs non
mais mais oui c'est des artistes qui ont
qui ont chacun comme tu dis tu sais que
ça va dans quel la continuité dans
laquelle s'inscrivent le type et que
tu es chaud Franco c'est
le but c'est d'objectif c'est de faire
quelque chose qui était mémorable
ce souci-là de tuer chaque chose qu'on
fait avec Ariane c'est que
toujours ajouter toujours peaufiner
toujours raffiner pour créer petit
mettons cette semaine on fait le
festival l'été on a fait des Francos
petit c'est tout le temps d'essayer de
mettre la barre toujours plus loin
possible de donner quelque chose de
de
bon là
c'est important pour eux pour elle de
créer un moment exceptionnel au moment
une formules peut-être un peu cliché
mais ça arrive quand même qu'on de voir
des artistes sur scène puis de sentir
qui sont peut-être un petit peu dans
dans leur pantoufles puis là ce serait
vraiment très difficile de leur
reprocher ça
ben merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
les gars c'était super c'était super si
vous êtes c'est super compliqué